J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Mais bonjour, j'espère que tout se passe bien pour vous. Ravi de vous retrouver. J'espère que la vie vous sourit.
Une personne pour qui tout ne se passe pas bien du tout en ce moment, c'est François De Smet, puisque le président de DéFI, le parti Démocrate Fédéraliste Indépendant, doit en ce moment gérer une crise énorme en interne.
Je me suis rendu au siège du parti et on en a longuement discuté ensemble. Mais pas seulement, puisqu'on a aussi parlé de sujets importants pour DéFI comme Bruxelles, la laïcité et le libéralisme.
Je vous souhaite une très bonne écoute. C'est parti. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec François De Smet. Bonjour François.
Bonjour.
François, vous êtes philosophe, écrivain, politicien bruxellois évidemment, aujourd'hui président de DéFI.
On vous connaît pour votre engagement sur plusieurs questions sociétales, éthiques, politiques, de la démocratie jusqu'aux questions identitaires en passant par les droits de l'homme.
Premier sujet, je le disais, vous êtes comme moi Bruxellois. On a vu récemment des actualités assez tragiques à Bruxelles : violences, meurtres par arme à feu, ici à Bruxelles, près de chez nous, là où on est né.
Quel regard est-ce que vous portez là-dessus aujourd'hui ? Est-ce que vous vous sentez en sécurité à Bruxelles ? Quelle réponse apporter ?
Alors, paradoxalement, je me sens pas en insécurité à Bruxelles, mais il faut reconnaître qu'on est face à une augmentation de la violence qui est préoccupante.
Alors, y a toujours une forme de violence liée aux grandes villes, indéniablement. Ce qui se passe à Bruxelles, c'est la conjonction de plusieurs facteurs.
Le premier d'entre eux, c'est l'extraordinaire croissance du trafic de drogue. Du trafic de drogue, donc de l'arrivée de la drogue via des conteneurs à Anvers.
On sait, via les quantités saisies qui ne sont qu'une part infime de ce qui circule réellement, que nous sommes, nous, la Belgique, une plaque tournante.
Il y a aussi un marché de la consommation qui a visiblement explosé, en particulier depuis le COVID ou la fin du COVID.
Et ce qui génère une offre, une demande et donc des trafics et donc des luttes de territoires entre des groupes organisés pour des points de deal. Et c'est,
c'est des règlements de comptes entre ces groupes qui amènent une forme de
de violence la plus préoccupante parce qu'elle se déploie avec des armes à feu et qu'elle peut, alors non seulement évidemment tuer les personnes concernées, mais par le biais de balles perdues, ce qui est déjà arrivé, toucher des innocents.
On présume que c'est lié au trafic de drogue. Pour l'instant, évidemment, vu que toutes les victimes sont décédées, on peut difficilement les interroger.
On le présume. Enfin, on a quand même, je crois, pas mal de données permettant de l'affirmer.
Se greffe là-dessus un trafic d'armes extrêmement présent.
Oui, c'est très intéressant parce qu'aux États-Unis, évidemment, très facile de se procurer des armes.
À Anderlecht aussi, c'est très facile de se procurer des armes. Avec mille euros, on peut trouver une Kalachnikov sans trop de difficulté, malheureusement.
Et cela se greffe aussi à la non-prise en charge d'un certain nombre de problèmes. Le fait qu'un grand nombre de sans-papiers, malheureusement, se mettent à errer,
dans les gares ou même de migrants devant être pris en charge par Fedasil.
Et une partie de ces gens,
ne serait-ce que pour survivre, soit se livrent au trafic de drogue, soit à des petites rapines, comme on dit, ou tombent même dans la consommation parce qu'ils ont une sorte de non-vie qui n'est pas simple à assumer.
Et ça génère quelque chose qui est en train de saisir nos villes.
Je recevais il y a quelques semaines, quelques mois, un ancien toxicomane qui m'expliquait que quand il a repris la consommation de cocaïne, il a découvert un nouveau monde où aujourd'hui,
un petit message WhatsApp à un numéro et puis dix minutes plus tard, un petit peu comme un Uber Eats, on a une livraison à domicile en trottinette.
Oui, ça va extrêmement vite. Ce qui d'ailleurs pose la question de la responsabilisation des consommateurs. Parce qu'on peut évidemment poursuivre les dealers, les trafiquants.
Alors nous, on a un programme assez fort là-dessus, axé sur le régalien et surtout sur la spécialisation des services et la lutte contre la criminalité financière.
C'est un énorme volet. Mais la question des consommateurs, on n'est pas pour poursuivre les consommateurs, bien sûr, mais il faut quand même que chacun se rende compte qu'il y a un souci de santé publique.
Ce qui renvoie à une question qui n'est pas juste celle de la drogue, qui est : comment se fait-il que notre société génère autant de gens qui ont un besoin de consommation de cocaïne ?
Partout. On en a trouvé récemment dans un cabinet ministériel. Je pense qu'on peut en trouver dans toute strate de la société, les plus aisés comme les plus précarisés.
Donc c'est un vrai phénomène par lequel, ben, un produit pourtant objectivement extrêmement dangereux devient un produit de consommation presque courante.
À quoi ça répond comme besoin ? Elle est là d'accord, mais pourquoi les gens la prennent-ils ?
Donc ce qui amène une question, une question liée et qui revient souvent, c'est : est-ce que vous êtes en faveur d'une dépénalisation, légalisation de, par exemple, le cannabis, par exemple, la cocaïne ?
Eh bien, justement, je crois qu'il faut choisir ses combats. Nous sommes en faveur d'une dépénalisation du cannabis. On pense même que le cannabis devrait être vendu par le biais de magasins administrés par l'État et que
cela procurerait sans doute des bénéfices assez conséquents.
Cela, selon nous, assécherait une partie de l'économie illicite et des trafics.
Je pense qu'il faut pas aller, par contre, jusqu'à la régularisation et la légalisation de la cocaïne, qui est une drogue beaucoup plus dangereuse,
qui là génère des trafics et des mafias et des cartels extrêmement violents.
Là, ce serait le mauvais message. Mais pour le cannabis, notamment parce que je le disais, il faut choisir ses combats, ça permettrait sans doute à une partie
des enquêteurs, de la police et de la justice de consacrer leurs moyens, non pas sur le trafic de cannabis, qui est, oui, certes, c'est pas bien, mais enfin, c'est pas la fin du monde,
et concentrer ses moyens sur la drogue dure et les horreurs qu'elle génère.
En ce compris, on le sait—
En termes de— on a des gens pris en otage, on a découvert des salles de torture dans des conteneurs, on a un ministre de la Justice qui a été quand même mis sous protection judiciaire.
Enfin, ça va très loin. On parle de gens, les trafiquants de cocaïne, qui ont les moyens de, par exemple, payer un docker dix mille euros juste pour qu'il tourne la tête deux minutes.
Donc face à cette puissance-là, cette puissance financière-là, je pense qu'il faut pouvoir choisir nos priorités et légaliser les drogues douces.
Hum, très bien, mais donc ça, la question de la consommation, effectivement, vous y avez répondu. La question des réponses et des ressources qu'on peut y allouer est également clarifiée.
Maintenant, la question de la sécurité, la question des balles perdues que vous évoquiez, comment est-ce qu'on y répond ?
Comment est-ce que... Dans un contexte, on va y venir un peu plus tard dans l'émission, mais dans un contexte où l'austérité arrive et où les ressources financières, les budgets, sont limités.
Et pourtant, pour nous, la prochaine législature doit être régalienne et se concentrer sur les besoins de base : police, justice, santé.
Alors, plus de police de proximité. Elle a été en large partie affaiblie et démantelée. La Suédoise surtout, c'est ce gouvernement-là qui a fait des coupes extrêmement sombres avant de commencer à corriger le tir.
On reste avec une police locale et une police fédérale sous-financées. Il y a une norme qui s'appelle la norme KUL et qui, en fait, défavorise objectivement les grandes villes.
C'est une question de vocation aussi. On a du mal à trouver des enquêteurs, des gens qui acceptent de faire ce travail.
Donc c'est une question de moyens et c'est une question de spécialisation. C'est-à-dire qu'on doit voir la lutte contre cette insécurité, ça peut être un peu plus de bleu en rue, ça, je pense que c'est nécessaire,
mais c'est aussi du bleu derrière des écrans.
Ce sont les gens qui vont se spécialiser sur la lutte contre la criminalité financière, sur le traquage du blanchiment d'argent.
Tout ça, ça demande en fait un haut degré de spécialisation. C'est des enquêteurs qu'on trouve pas sous le sabot d'un cheval.
Et c'est pourtant bien plus rémunérateur. C'est pour nous un investissement. On l'a vu avec M. Scless qui nous a rejoints.
Quand il nous parle des centaines de millions d'euros qu'il est déjà arrivé à récupérer dans la lutte contre le blanchiment, on pourrait réinjecter immédiatement cet argent-là dans la lutte contre le trafic et dans la promotion de
la sécurité et de la justice.
Donc une partie des moyens, ils peuvent venir, il suffit d'aller les chercher là où ils se trouvent, c'est-à-dire dans la poche des criminels.
D'accord. Hum, vous parliez du renforcement de la police locale.
Une arlésienne qui revient souvent dans la bouche de certaines figures politiques, c'est la question des sections policières à Bruxelles et la fusion éventuellement des différentes unités.
Les dix-neuf communes de Bruxelles éventuellement fusionnées en une seule grande région ou bien spécifiquement sur la police, quelle est votre vision là-dessus ?
Je suis pas très favorable parce que d'abord, comme Bruxellois, comme vous, je mesure tout de même que les communes, elles respirent une forme d'identité.
C'est, voilà, y a rien à faire. Chaque commune a une identité propre et qu'on y tient et qu'on n'est pas juste un district d'une grande agglomération qui s'appelle, qui s'appelle—
Uccle n'est pas Schaerbeek.
Par exemple. Alors, on pourrait même interroger le côté négatif de cela, parce qu'il existe. C'est qu'on se retrouve aussi avec dix-neuf, voire plus, entités qui parfois ne se parlent pas.
C'est très frappant de voir que les sujets, les vies, les villes sont— Il y a plusieurs villes à Bruxelles qui coexistent.
Le croissant pauvre n'est pas le bourgeois, bobo du sud, qui n'est pas encore le Bruxelles des eurocrates qui ne fréquentent personne.
Tout ça se superpose. Et c'est assez intéressant de voir qu'à Bruxelles, ce sont les dossiers qui forcent un peu le croisement des gens, comme le métro, le piétonnier, qui posent le plus de questions. Néanmoins, moi, je—
La sécurité.
Comme la sécurité. Je crois pas, moi, à une fusion. C'est un vieux fantasme flamand aussi, du nationalisme flamand visant à affaiblir
les Bruxellois en les fondant dans une forme de grand district qui, même idéalement, serait coadministré, pourquoi pas, par les Flamands et les Wallons.
Moi, je crois que les Bruxellois ont leur destin en main. Ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des efforts à faire. Par exemple, à partir de la prochaine législature, il y aura un échevin de moins dans chaque commune.
C'est une réforme qui a été décidée il y a un moment déjà. Je crois que c'est rationnel. Je crois qu'il y a sans doute des déperditions de moyens à éviter.
Nous, DéFI, nous avons aussi installé le décumul avec le gouvernement qui achève ses travaux. C'est-à-dire qu'il ne sera désormais plus possible d'être à la fois député et bourgmestre ou échevin.
Il faudra choisir, ce que je trouve très bien, parce que ce sont des métiers,
à Bruxelles en tout cas, à plein temps. Je dis pas : vous êtes bourgmestre ou échevin d'une petite commune,
mais ici à Bruxelles, y a quasiment pas de vraies petites communes et même les plus petites peuvent, à mon avis, devoir se gérer avec un bourgmestre à plein temps.
Et je trouve ça sain et ça fait partie de la solution.
Hum. Combiner une occupation de président de parti et par exemple de député à la Chambre ou par exemple de sénateur, est-ce que ce ne sont pas deux occupations à temps plein qui sont difficiles à combiner ?
Si. Deux précisions là-dessus, elles ne sont pas rémunérées. Enfin, je ne suis pas rémunéré comme président, donc je suis président à titre gratuit.
Néanmoins, j'ai pas de problème à le dire, c'est une anomalie que nous devons subir simplement parce que nous n'aurions pas chez DéFI les moyens de payer un président convenablement.
Disons que pour le payer, on devrait peut-être au moins quand même le payer autant qu'un député, ce qui me semblerait normal.
Ce serait idiot de devoir licencier deux personnes et demi pour engager un président. Donc, nous cumulons, mais ce n'est pas idéal, ce n'est pas un cumul financier.
Et moi, je pense que c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas tenable. D'abord, ce n'est pas tenable humainement. Je n'ai pas de week-end, je n'ai pas de nuit parce que je fais réellement, moi, mon travail de député fédéral.
On peut me croiser quasiment tous les trois jours ou tous les deux jours ou tous les jours à la Chambre, selon les sujets.
Donc, je tiens à respecter ce mandat pris auprès des électeurs. C'est donc le mandat de président qui est parfois en pâtie.
Mais humainement et en termes de charge de travail, c'est pas tenable. Donc idéalement, non, un président de parti ne devrait faire que ça.
J'ai pas de problème à le reconnaître, mais nous ne sommes pas parfaits, mais nous espérons arriver vers un tel décumul dès que possible.
Voilà. Et on aura compris votre petite référence à d'autres présidents de parti qui occupent également des fonctions au fédéral.
Et que je ne croise pas souvent au Sénat.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Donc, je le disais il y a un instant, l'austérité qui s'annonce, voilà, des accords qui ont été ou qui sont
sur le point d'être négociés entre— enfin, non, même plus que négociés, des accords qui ont été faits entre la Commission européenne,
le Conseil sous la présidence de la Belgique et le Parlement européen, qui va bientôt avoir éventuellement l'occasion
de s'y opposer, mais rien n'est moins sûr.
Comment se passe la campagne électorale chez DéFI, par exemple, quand on doit promettre des améliorations, promettre un meilleur lendemain et en même temps voir arriver l'austérité ?
C'est une bonne question parce qu'elle touche aussi les aspects climat. On en parlera peut-être après.
Bien sûr, puisque cet accord permet l'investissement dans la défense, dans la numérisation, dans le vieillissement de la population et également dans les aspects du climat.
Et ce sont des bonnes causes. Et si l'Europe ne devait servir qu'à une chose, c'est de tracer les lignes de notre destin commun.
C'est logique, au fond,
que sur le plan de la défense, on voit bien le monde tel qu'il évolue, avec le retour probable d'un Trump qui a déjà déclaré qu'il ne défendrait pas spécialement les Européens,
une Russie qui n'a jamais eu l'air aussi impérialiste, des Européens qui, depuis la chute du mur, sont peut-être trop habitués à se dire que ok, c'est gagné, nous sommes une grande Suisse et rien ne peut nous arriver et profitons de la vie.
Nous sommes simplement en train de sortir de cela. Les pays européens qui songent au retour du service militaire. On entre vraiment dans un monde assez angoissant.
Deuxièmement, le climat. C'est un sujet qui réclame aussi des investissements qui dépassent non seulement la prochaine législature, mais même les prochaines générations.
C'est ce qui rend intuitivement très difficile d'y réfléchir en démocratie, parce qu'on doit prendre des décisions qui ne nous impacteront peut-être même pas nous-mêmes, mais plus sûrement nos enfants ou nos petits-enfants.
Et puis, il y a ce mur parfois trop administratif et budgétaire de la Commission européenne qui nous dit : Il va falloir économiser autant de milliards.
Même si la cause est bonne, je dis simplement attention au rythme et au tempo. Moi, j'ai le souvenir que dans l'après-crise financière de 2008,
les économies européennes et occidentales d'ailleurs étaient par terre
et que les Américains, qui sont pourtant à l'origine de la crise des subprimes,
ont finalement beaucoup plus vite rebondi et renoué avec la croissance que nous, parce que nous nous étions enfermés, nous, Européens, dans une politique austéritaire excessive.
Toute la question est là. Comment— le meilleur moyen de remplir les caisses de l'État et d'arriver notamment à un désendettement et un déficit maîtrisé, c'est d'avoir une activité,
de relever le taux d'emploi, comme on l'a fait entre nous à Bruxelles, de soixante-deux à soixante-huit pour cent avec notre ministre DéFI de l'emploi, et donc d'arriver le plus possible vers les quatre-vingt pour cent.
Si vous arrivez à quatre-vingt pour cent de taux d'emploi, vous n'avez plus de déficit du tout. C'est quand même assez...
Et donc, la solution reste là. Mais comment arriver à cela sans tuer la part de l'économie qui a forcément besoin de cette croissance et donc sans trop d'austérité ?
Ça, c'est extrêmement compliqué. Il faut trouver les bons boutons pour faire pression entre une pression fiscale qui doit sans doute s'alléger sur les revenus du travail pour encourager le travail, entre
un esprit d'entreprendre qui n'est pas assez favorisé.
Je trouve que c'est trop compliqué d'entreprendre en Belgique.
On a historiquement, en Belgique, été les derniers de l'OCDE et l'Union européenne en termes de taux de création d'entreprises.
Donc, on n'a pas vraiment l'esprit d'entreprendre.
Moi, ce qui me frappe, c'est que c'est quasiment culturel. On a cinq axes chez DéFI, de programme. On en a consacré un entier, le numéro trois, à la liberté d'entreprendre.
Il y a un chiffre que je cite souvent parce qu'il me frappe. Il existe un statut d'étudiant entrepreneur dans notre pays.
Il est utilisé à quatre-vingt pour cent par des néerlandophones. Ils sont nombreux, mais quand même, quatre-vingt pour cent, c'est beaucoup.
Ça veut dire qu'il y a vraiment, les Wallons et les Bruxellois ne sont que vingt pour cent à utiliser cette faculté. C'est le genre de chiffre qui nous montre à quel point c'est culturellement ancré, malheureusement.
Tant en Wallonie qu'à Bruxelles, on n'a pas spontanément beaucoup de jeunes qui se disent : « Je vais créer ma boîte ». Et même quand ils le font, ils sont parfois vus comme des bêtes curieuses.
Ils ne sont pas encouragés et ce n'est pas favorisé.
On pourrait argumenter aussi qu'entreprendre, ça reste une prise de risque, un luxe de personnes qui sont peut-être un petit peu plus favorisées financièrement.
Et on connaît les inégalités entre le nord et le sud du pays.
Assurément, ça joue. Mais il y a aussi des gens, des jeunes précarisés qui peuvent commencer à entreprendre. On sait tous qu'il y a des métiers qui sont porteurs d'emplois.
Si vous décidez de vous lancer dans l'isolation des maisons, le placement de pompes à chaleur, vous avez des jobs, vous avez du travail pour trente ans.
À mon avis, ça doit même être très rémunérateur. Il ne faut pas hésiter. Donc, il n'y a pas que le petit gars du Brabant wallon qui a un capital familial de papa et de maman et qui a une bonne idée de biotechnologie.
Il y a d'autres choses possibles. On peut aussi entreprendre à tout niveau dès qu'on est un petit peu... Et même ça, culturellement, on a l'impression que ce n'est pas flagramment présent.
J'ai été dans ma vie, j'ai fait pas mal de choses,
mais j'étais notamment directeur du Naïm Home. On est dans le secteur de l'aide à la jeunesse, c'est des petites ASBL qui font de la prévention et qui aident les jeunes en difficulté qui errent dans les rues, pour le dire vite.
Jamais aucun d'entre eux, que j'ai croisés, ne voulaient fonder une boîte. C'était trouver le chemin d'un job, d'une formation au mieux ou du CPAS, ou éventuellement, pourquoi pas, d'un enseignement supérieur si on se sentait capable.
Jamais personne n'avait un projet entrepreneurial, jamais personne n'avait des entrepreneurs comme role model. Ça, quand même, on a du chemin à faire.
C'est pour ça que dans notre plan, ça va de l'école, l'implémentation de l'esprit d'entreprendre,
jusque dans les cursus scolaires, à l'enseignement supérieur, jusque, une fois qu'on est entrepreneur, au fait de simplifier la vie des gens, notamment en les relaxant d'une série de charges administratives qui sont trop demandées.
J'ai l'impression que ce problème de manquement de role model et de crise d'esprit d'entreprendre en Belgique, je pense qu'on en parle depuis, on va dire, une dizaine d'années, voire beaucoup plus loin, si on cherche.
Je sais que c'est une grande préoccupation de Cécile Jodogne, par exemple, chez DéFI.
C'est aussi le fruit, le résultat, si on compare par exemple avec les États-Unis, où le filet social est inexistant ou presque inexistant, où la prise de risque est une obligation pour survivre.
Pour le dire comme ça, c'est tu marches ou tu crèves. Ici, on a un filet social beaucoup plus important. C'est sans doute une partie de ce qui explique le fait qu'on a moins le besoin d'entreprendre.
Le piège à l'emploi, il est réel. C'est un vrai problème dont les politiques n'arrivent pas, nous compris peut-être, à dénouer le nœud.
C'est que la différence entre le fait de travailler et de pas travailler n'est pas assez importante. Moi, je pense qu'il faut un matelas social et c'est très bien.
Je pense qu'on peut être fier d'être dans une société où, même quand vous avez un accident de la vie ou vous avez un problème ou que vous avez des enfants, vous êtes aidé par la société, ça me semble formidablement bien et nécessaire.
La question, c'est qu'y a un moment où, en effet, si la différence entre le fait de se lever le matin pour aller travailler et de ne pas le faire est trop faible, voire pénalise le travailleur, c'est qu'il y a un problème.
C'est pour ça que la seule vraie réforme fiscale à faire, et celle consistant à très largement détaxer les bas et les moyens salaires.
Pourquoi les moyens salaires ?
Parce que c'est les grands perdants actuels. Il y a toute une série de personnes qui sont juste trop pauvres pour vivre de manière un peu convenable, avec un peu de confort, pour, en ce compris des vacances, un restaurant de temps en temps,
mais qui sont juste trop riches pour bénéficier des allocations sociales et d'une série de facultés comme la,
la crèche gratuite et que sais-je.
Et cette portion-là de la population, elle a vraiment l'impression de se faire avoir. Et celle-là, elle doit donc être un peu plus chouchoutée.
Ça veut dire-- ça veut pas dire qu'on doit nécessairement rogner sur les prestations sociales, c'est qu'il faut que le travail paye mieux.
Moi, je pense qu'à partir d'un différentiel de cinq cents euros, vous pouvez convaincre les gens de se lever le matin et d'aller travailler.
Ça n'empêche pas aussi qu'on doit, pour les demandeurs d'emploi qui restent demandeurs d'emploi longtemps, pouvoir être un tout petit peu plus coercitifs.
Attention, pas comme un couperet. Moi, je pense pas, contrairement à d'autres partis, qu'il faut un arrêt après deux ans des allocations.
Par contre, je dirais qu'après une certaine durée, comme par exemple un an, on est fondé à dire aux chercheurs d'emploi : "Bah écoutez, voilà, après un an, normalement, y a quand même beaucoup de gens qui retrouvent un emploi, vous non.
Donc il serait peut-être temps d'envisager quelque chose de plus fort au niveau de votre, d'un plan de formation. Formez-vous soit dans un métier en pénurie, soit dans un métier qui ne l'est pas."
Moi, je pense qu'il faut pas condamner les gens à devenir chauffeur de bus ou placeur de panneaux photovoltaïques.
Nécessairement, il y a des tas de jobs qui existent. Mais qu'on mette la contrainte sur la formation et qu'on fasse dépendre l'octroi d'allocation d'une obligation de formation plutôt que de faire comme un couperet,
si, s'il ne se passe rien, ça me semble plus positif parce que c'est ça le problème.
La main-d'œuvre, on l'a, elle n'est pas formée. Les entreprises, elles pleurent pour avoir de la main-d'œuvre. Dans les métiers en pénurie, il y a des tas d'entreprises qui ne trouvent pas.
Et à côté de ça, on a des gens qui n'ont pas les compétences requises, même si,
notamment pour les jeunes, on formait énormément, ici à Bruxelles notamment, sur les langues et le numérique qui sont, ben, les deux champs sur lesquels il nous paraît possible d'avoir des gens extrêmement polyvalents rapidement.
Ça pose la question des investissements, voilà, dans ces formations et de l'équilibre budgétaire que sur le long terme, on va éventuellement pouvoir obtenir en diminuant le taux de chômage, tout ça dans un cadre d'austérité.
Oui, ça va pas être simple. Moi, je pense que les prochains gouvernements sont ceux qui vont devoir faire sans doute les choix les plus ardus sur le plan économique, budgétaire et financier.
Alors, il y a peut-être un petit dégraissage des services publics à faire, mais on va pas se leurrer. Je vois aussi le côté un peu tendancieusement populiste de certains acteurs.
Même si vous vous mettiez à demander aux députés, aux ministres de travailler gratuitement, vous combleriez que zéro virgule zéro zéro zéro zéro un pour cent du déficit en cours.
Donc ça veut dire que vous pouvez faire des économies un petit peu sur le travail, 'fin, sur ce que fait l'État, mais vous ne pouvez-- vous devez surtout augmenter les recettes en faisant, sans augmenter le temps d'emploi.
Et donc on en revient à la formation et aux besoins des entreprises. Et enfin, il y a un sujet qui est, je crois, totalement sous-estimé, qui va, à mon avis, s'imposer peut-être même dans la campagne, c'est les malades de longue durée.
Il y a aujourd'hui plus de malades de longue durée dans notre pays que de personnes qui cherchent un emploi. C'est quand même un problème et je ne les blâme pas.
Encore une fois, on en parlait tout à l'heure sur la cocaïne. Qu'est-ce que ça dit de notre société ? Un monde où vous avez de manière massive des problèmes de burn-out, des problèmes mentaux.
Et je ne crois pas, moi, qu'il s'agisse de faux problèmes, même s'il y a sans doute quelques personnes qui abusent, qu'il faut pouvoir débusquer ou sanctionner.
Mais je crois que la majorité, bien sûr que non. Je pense qu'en majorité, il y a un vrai mal-être au travail.
Il y a des gens qui ne se retrouvent pas dans le travail qu'ils font ou qui se pensent ou qui sont victimes de harcèlement.
Et donc la question du bien-être au travail. Mais c'est aussi, ça répond aussi à la question de la formation et de l'orientation.
Confucius disait : "Choisis un travail que tu aimes et tu ne travailleras aucun autre jour de ta vie." Il y a quand même toute une partie de la population.
Il y a des gens qui sont très heureux de leur travail,
et pour qui c'est un vrai bonheur et qui ne voient, qui ne font--
pour eux, le travail est quelque chose qui ne commence pas à huit heures et qui se termine à seize, dix-sept heures, mais qui fait partie de leur vie.
Et il y a des gens pour qui la vraie vie ne commence qu'à dix-sept heures ou dix-huit heures quand ils sortent du travail.
Ça, ça ne va pas. En tout cas, c'est pas le modèle qu'on peut espérer. Comment faire en sorte que le travail ait du sens pour tout le monde ?
Et ça, je sens les nouvelles générations extrêmement demandeuses. Le fait, par exemple, qu'on ait du mal à trouver du personnel dans l'Horeca depuis la fin du Covid alors que c'était quand même le cas avant.
Tous les restaurateurs que je rencontre me disent : "Ben, on trouve plus de jeunes qui acceptent de servir des plats, de faire de la plonge."
Ils veulent tous, même pour un travail temporaire et mal payé, quelque chose qui ait du sens. Alors, on peut s'en moquer, mais l'exigence de sens, c'est, je trouve, extrêmement intéressant. Et c'est un-
Très propre à la génération Z.
Exactement. Et bon, voilà. Alors, elle a sûrement ses défauts aussi, cette génération, mais là, elle nous apprend sans doute quelque chose.
Je crois qu'une partie des gens, 'fin, ce n'est qu'un postulat hein, une partie de ces nombreuses personnes qui sont malades de longue durée, sont des gens qui ne trouvent pas de sens à leur travail.
Comment on peut faire pour les aider ? Je n'ai pas la-
Vous spéculez.
Pardon ?
Vous spéculez. Vous-
Je spécule, je spécule complètement, mais si vous voulez, la politique n'est pas une science exacte. Mais on est bien not-- Je pense hein, j'essaie de rester philosophe.
J'essaie de rester philosophe dans tout ce que je fais. Je crois qu'on doit être autorisé à spéculer, on peut faire des erreurs.
Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Mais il se passe quelque chose là, dans la question du monde du travail. Et on doit, je pense qu'on doit lutter contre cet absentéisme autrement qu'en envoyant des contrôleurs tous azimuts.
Il doit y avoir autre chose. Je sais pas, moi. Est-ce que ça tient au bien-être au travail ? Est-ce que ça tient à la lutte contre le harcèlement ?
Est-ce que ça tient à la possibilité beaucoup plus facile de faire, d'avoir de la mobilité pour démissionner d'un poste et pouvoir aller très facilement changer pour-- parce qu'on a tous besoin de changer d'air, peut-être tout simplement.
Je trouve que ça, c'est un sujet qui n'est pas assez mis en avant et que j'aimerais bien, moi, plus pousser.
Vous êtes un philosophe formidable puisque à ma question, vous avez répondu avec une vingtaine d'autres questions et je vais en rajouter une autre.
Super, super, mais d'aller plus loin.
Je vais en rajouter une autre. Je pense que certains à gauche répondraient à vos questions, de la question du burn-out assez récurrent, du besoin de sens, etc.
Au fait que c'est peut-être propre à un néolibéralisme, à un capitalisme excessif qui appuie trop ou qui cherche l'exploitation de la population qui, finalement, se retrouve écrasée.
Alors, je suis libéral.
Oui, oui.
Je suis pas libéral comme le MR, mais je pense moi que l'économie de marché est quand même--
L'histoire, pour l'instant, le montre, la doctrine politique et le régime, c'est-à-dire l'alliance entre les libertés individuelles et la liberté d'entreprendre et de créer et la démocratie, ce qui tient le mieux.
Je lis souvent mes amis de gauche, même s'ils sont pas tous d'extrême gauche, jamais personne n'a essayé de franchir le mur de Berlin dans l'autre sens.
Il y a un moment où quand vous êtes complètement collectivisé et que le médecin gagne autant que l'ouvrier, vous n'avez pas non plus de sens à votre travail et vous avez aussi de l'exploitation.
Donc comment trouver le bon curseur ? À mon avis, en gardant la liberté de créer et de pouvoir plus facilement changer d'emploi et en luttant contre les abus.
C'est vrai que le fait que des sans-papiers, par exemple, soient exploités par
des plateformes de livraison de repas, même si la livraison de repas, moi, je trouve ça bien en soi, mais que le fait que ce soit un lieu d'exploitation, que les gens soient pas bien payés,
ne cotisent pas assez pour leurs cotisations sociales, voire même soient sans papiers, ne va pas.
Ce sont des secteurs qui, pour moi, doivent rester. C'est de l'économie nouvelle et c'est intéressant, mais ils doivent être régulés, quitte à coûter beaucoup plus cher.
Si votre pizza coûte une fois et demie plus chère en venant la livrer, moi, je trouve ça plutôt normal parce qu'il faut que les gens qui font ça soient correctement payés.
Et donc l'État est là pour ça. Il est là pour corriger les excès d'un libéralisme qui, si vous le laissez tout seul déréguler, en effet, produit de l'exploitation, ça, il y a aucun doute.
C'est à nous de trouver le juste curseur.
Et donc le nombre effroyable de maladies longue durée en Belgique francophone serait le résultat d'un libéralisme-
Mh.
Dérégulé ?
Bah non, parce qu'à droite, on vous dira au contraire, il est le fruit d'un système d'État-providence trop généreux.
Vous êtes au centre, donc ça tombe bien.
Bah voilà, qui pousse trop facilement les gens à rester chez eux et en tirer des avantages. Peut-être que les deux sont vrais.
Peut-être que dans les malades de longue durée, vous avez des gens qui se sentent écrasés, exploités par un employeur, donc déprimés.
Mais vous avez aussi des gens qui, allez, qui quand même profitent un petit peu plus du système parce que le système permet de le faire.
Je crois qu'il y a beaucoup moins de malades de longue durée dans les pays où le licenciement est plus facile, par exemple.
Donc c'est ça qui est difficile. Nous, peut-être avec notre côté à la fois latin et,
et germain, nous accueillons à la fois beaucoup de systèmes différents et nous avons du mal à mettre de l'ordre parce que peut-être que nous coagulons les désavantages des deux systèmes de pensée.
Moi, je crois que c'est jouable. Il y a moyen de ne pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain.
Vous êtes vraiment centriste ou...
Pourtant j'aime pas le mot centrisme.
On va revenir là-dessus. J'aime pas non plus. Mais vous-- Mais dans votre réponse, vous m'expliquez que peut-être la gauche a un petit peu raison, peut-être la droite a un petit peu raison.
Sur certains sujets, oui, c'est le cas. Vous voulez que je vous explique si on est-- Vous voulez que je vous dise si on est de gauche ou de droite ?
C'est pas nécessaire de s'immiscer à ça. Je-- Au centre du programme et de l'idéologie chez DéFI, il y a une question récurrente importante, donc le libéralisme social, on vient d'en parler un petit peu, et aussi la laïcité.
On va en parler maintenant. Reste à savoir quelle est votre vision exacte de la laïcité. Vous êtes l'auteur de Deus Casino, un essai dans lequel vous vous penchez entre autres sur le pastafarisme.
Donc pour expliquer un petit peu, le pastafarisme, c'est une espèce de blague, comme, voilà, une espèce de pseudo religion qui vénérerait un monstre spaghetti volant et dont les fidèles portent alors un évatoire.
Une passoire.
Voilà, une passoire pour spaghetti sur le crâne. Donc c'est assez moqueur, hein, moqueur de la religion.
Est-ce que c'est, voilà. Est-ce que-- Finalement, dans votre livre, vous vous demandez si derrière cette blague, il y a pas en fait une forme de lucidité.
Qu'est-ce que cet intérêt candide, cette fascination pour le pastafarisme dit sur vous, François De Smet, et sur la vision de la laïcité et la religion chez DéFI ?
Oh, mais c'est deux choses différentes.
Ah, vous séparez l'homme du parti ?
Mais toujours.
D'accord.
Nous sommes des individus et de-- Moi, ce que je gère, c'est un parti politique, c'est pas une secte.
Ça dépend des partis.
Pardon ?
Ça dépend des partis, mais chez moi, c'est pas une secte. Il y a une liberté d'expression assez vivace. Je crois que ça se voit peut-être un peu trop parfois, mais soit.
Comme philosophe, je fais des essais. J'ai plus le temps pour l'instant, mais je...
Vous en avez fait beaucoup.
Ouais, mais quand je ne serai plus président, je reprendrai.
Vous en avez fait pendant votre présidence aussi hein.
Bah oui, mais enfin, il était largement préparé avant.
D'accord, maintenant.
Sincèrement, depuis que je fais ce job-là, j'ai plus le temps d'écrire mes listes de courses. Je sais pas comment font Paul Magnette et les autres. Moi, j'ai,
j'ai plus le temps. Je sais pas comment font les autres, sincèrement. Et ça me manque.
Mais donc du temps pas si lointain où j'écrivais des essais, des petits essais de philosophie très, très modestes, mais qui marchaient quand même correctement,
je prenais quel est le bug dans la matrice ?
Quel est-- je pars toujours d'une anecdote de quelque chose qui me permet après de traiter un vrai grand sujet.
C'est aussi un petit peu ce qui est le sujet de ce podcast.
Bah voilà. Donc le point Godwin qui est le premier livre fait avec Laurent de Sutter au PUF, c'était une manière de traiter de la question du mal.
Et ici, Deus Casino, c'est une manière-- le pastafarisme, c'est une manière sympa de traiter de l'épineuse question de la religion, mais sans faire un traité un peu lourd et pénible que personne ne va lire.
Parce que les pastafariens, d'abord, ils ne vont jamais que ressusciter un vieil argument, celui de la théière de Bertrand Russell.
La théière de Bertrand Russell, c'est cette idée donc du philosophe sceptique britannique Bertrand Russell consistant à dire
: imaginons qu'une théière flotte entre la planète Terre et Mars et que cette théière soit trop petite pour être aperçue par le plus puissant des télescopes.
Je puis sans risque dire que cette théière existe et fonder même une croyance dessus puisque personne ne pourra jamais me prouver que cette théière n'existe pas.
Et donc l'idée de Russell est d'en dire : en fait, toutes les religions fonctionnent comme ça.
C'est parce qu'il est impossible de prouver l'inexistence de quelque chose, ça vaut pour Dieu, mais ça vaut aussi pour les licornes ou les Schtroumpfs, que la croyance bénéficiera toujours d'un support
de cet avantage, de ce privilège de ne pas avoir à se confronter aux probabilités et au vrai sens.
Parce que si on réfléchit deux secondes, il est quand même très peu probable que cette théière existe. Mais comme même une chance sur un milliard ou une dizaine de milliards existe, par respect pour les croyants, cette chance doit exister.
Ce que sous-entend Russell, c'est que Dieu a autant de chances d'exister que cette théière en porcelaine.
Bien sûr.
Et les pastafariens, ils sont intéressants parce que d'abord, ils font quelque chose qui est assez gag évidemment en inventant une fausse religion de toutes pièces.
Sauf que ça marche, qu'il y a des croyants, il y a des fidèles, il y a des gens qui se prêtent au jeu, il y a des pastafariens sur tous les continents.
Quand vous dites que ça marche, c'est toujours au second degré.
Bien sûr, mais... Sauf que-- alors ça, ça marche pourquoi ? Bien sûr, les gens savent que ce n'est pas une vraie religion.
Mais de un, ça donne un fanion de rassemblement aux athées et aux agnostiques. Parce que le A de athée ou le A de agnostique le rappelle, c'est d'abord une privation.
Donc c'est pas un fanion de rassemblement que de ne pas croire ou que de douter. Tout à coup, ça le devient par le biais d'un truc que la plupart des religions détestent, c'est-à-dire l'humour et le côté potache.
Et en plus, ça met la réflexion au bon endroit. Mais je-- Il y a d'autres cas avec les pastafariens, les rosicruciens, par exemple.
Le mouvement Rose-Croix est né d'une blague d'étudiants en théologie allemands qui ont fait semblant qu'existait un certain Christian Rosenkreutz.
Il est mort, on a retrouvé ses écrits et on a fondé une doctrine dessus. Et ils se sont pris au jeu et ça a fondé un vrai mouvement.
Un mouvement qui a subsisté même quand la supercherie a été découverte. Et ça, ça m'intéresse. Qui sait si toutes les religions existantes ne sont pas nées en fait comme les Rose-Croix, voire comme les pastafariens, avec une forme d'oubli.
Il suffit qu'un jour quelqu'un invente quelque chose d'un petit peu extravagant avec toujours des points communs. Il faut un parangon, un prophète.
C'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui soit le lien entre les hommes et Dieu. Vous avez ça dans toutes les grandes religions du livre.
Moïse, bien sûr Jésus qui lui va très loin en étant à la fois cent pour cent homme et cent pour cent Dieu, Mohammed.
Vous avez ça partout. Quelqu'un qui fasse le lien entre l'irrationnel, le surnaturel et le très réel avec des phases de vie dont on peut vraiment s'alimenter.
C'est toujours les mêmes recettes et ce sont des recettes qui marchent extrêmement vite parce que le cerveau humain est prédisposé et a même besoin de croire.
Et c'est pas nécessairement négatif. La religion, moi, je vois ça comme une sorte d'ombre d'arbre au nombre de laquelle il faut grandir, mais pouvoir se détacher parce qu'au bout d'un moment, ça devient toujours oppressant.
Mais les êtres humains se sont créé des religions pour s'inventer des raisons d'être ensemble et des règles. Et donc c'est tout cela, avec le besoin de croire, pourquoi est-ce qu'on est si crédules, nous, les humains ?
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on en a tellement besoin ? Quelle est la fonction sociale de cela ? C'est ça qui, l'air de rien, juste avec ce côté un petit peu gag
de ces types qui se mettent une passoire sur la tête, il y a moyen, c'est ce que j'essaie modestement de faire,
de livrer une véritable réflexion sur le phénomène religieux dont je ne me moque pas par ailleurs, même si je ne suis pas croyant, je suis très respectueux.
Vous ne vous moquez pas, mais vous employez des termes comme : la religion, il faut pouvoir s'en libérer. Vous parlez de la religion en disant : je ne dis pas ça de manière négative.
On sent quand même un petit biais,
Alors—
Un petit biais, je dirais antithéiste, peut-être ?
Non, moi, je suis— d'abord, je visite toujours les lieux de culte avec plaisir. J'ai des amis de toutes les croyances et de toutes les religions et je suis pas un laïc obtus.
La laïcité n'est pas l'opposition aux religions, c'est leur condition d'existence. C'est grâce à la laïcité qu'aucune conviction religieuse ou politique ne l'emporte sur les autres.
Et c'est grâce à la laïcité politique bien comprise, donc pas la laïcité philosophique telle qu'on la conçoit parfois en Belgique, c'est-à-dire là, la promotion ouverte de l'athéisme et de l'agnosticisme, c'est pas mon propos.
C'est vraiment la séparation des Églises et des États pour éviter que toute croyance religieuse ou politique ne l'emporte sur les autres.
La neutralité dans les services publics, c'est ça. Ça ne vise pas spécialement le voile islamique, mais ça vise toutes les religions et toutes les convictions pour les préserver les unes et les autres.
Et ça, c'est un bel idéal qui, théoriquement, s'il est correctement compris, devrait pouvoir aussi rassembler les croyants.
C'est d'ailleurs le cas. Il y a des croyants qui comprennent tout à fait l'intérêt de la laïcité politique telle que je viens de l'énoncer.
Et on a besoin d'eux d'ailleurs. Ça n'empêche pas de pouvoir vivre votre religion comme vous l'entendez, tant que vous respectez les lois.
En ce compris d'ailleurs dans l'espace public. Moi, je fais pas partie de ces gens qui croient qu'il faudrait s'abstenir de signes convictionnels dans l'espace public.
Chacun a le droit de porter un t-shirt PS, un pin's DéFI ou un voile ou un turban. Ça, y a pas de problème. Ça ne touche que certaines fonctions, l'exigence de neutralité.
Ça ne touche jamais les citoyens et les usagers.
Vous n'êtes pas Nadia Geerts.
Nadia, à mon avis, Geerts serait d'accord avec ce que je viens de vous dire.
Ah, parce qu'elle, elle a tendance plutôt à être agacée de l'apparition de signes de conviction dans l'espace public.
Dans l'espace public— je l'ai vu tweeter notamment sur quelqu'un qui s'est fait reprocher d'avoir un voile dans un bus et elle a tweeté dans le bon sens, à savoir que—
D'accord, ok. Autant pour moi.
Aux usagers, il faut leur foutre la paix. Alors, je partage pas tous les points de vue de Nadia, mais sincèrement, sur ce coup-là, je pense qu'on serait plutôt d'accord.
D'accord, OK. Donc, vous vous rapprochez alors, par exemple, d'une Caroline Fourest en France qui est un peu pointée comme étant l'équivalent français de Nadia Geerts.
Oui, j'aime bien Caroline Fourest parce que je la trouve en plus courageuse dans ses combats, que ce soit contre l'extrême droite, l'islamisme.
Elle fait— y a toute cette gauche-là quand même, avec Fourest, avec Sophia Aram, avec cette gauche française qui se libère de l'autre gauche française ou belge qui a tendance à flirter de manière trop forte avec une forme de communautarisme.
Et il faut du courage. Il faut du courage parce que vraiment, c'est quelque chose qui prend un terrain politiquement, on le voit même en Belgique, chez nous, assez formidable.
Et ces voix de gauche, elles sont rares en France, elles sont rares aussi en Belgique, mais elles sont courageuses. C'est-à-dire ces gens de gauche qui, bêtement, osent encore nous parler de laïcité.
Et nous, on a récupéré la laïcité, notamment parce que la gauche l'a laissée tomber et qu'il fallait quelqu'un pour ramasser le flambeau.
Et l'autre gauche n'est pas courageuse ?
Non. Il y a une gauche qui part du principe qu'une femme musulmane qui défend, qui réclame, par exemple, le droit de porter
un foulard dans l'administration est nécessairement une prolétaire discriminée qu'il faut pouvoir aider dans un schéma marxisant.
Moi, je crois pas que c'est ça. Je crois pas que c'est ça du tout. Et je crois que
les lois doivent protéger tout le monde et qu'elles doivent aussi protéger,
en l'occurrence, par exemple, les femmes musulmanes qui n'ont pas envie d'être dans des milieux où elles doivent, par
pression sociale, finir par porter des signes convictionnels et que la loi doit protéger le plus faible et que c'est ça que la gauche est en train d'oublier.
Parce que je crois que c'est plus profitable, notamment électoralement, d'être les défenseurs des damnés de la terre.
Là, par exemple, aujourd'hui, des femmes qui portent un foulard, même si en fait, c'est une réalité beaucoup plus complexe qu'elle en a l'air.
Très bien. Donc là, vous êtes revenu sur votre essai Deus Casino, vous vous êtes étendu sur votre rapport à la religion, sur la laïcité, la neutralité.
Est-ce que ces positions-là sont aussi celles de DéFI alors, puisque vous vous êtes séparé en début de votre intervention ?
Dans l'ensemble, oui. DéFI est un parti qui promeut la laïcité politique, telle que je viens de la décrire.
DéFI est un parti qui compte des croyants de toutes les religions, des musulmans, des catholiques, des protestants, des athées, des agnostiques.
Et c'est parce qu'on a bien défini, je pense, notre laïcité comme n'étant pas excluante, mais comme étant la condition d'expression des religions que ça marche.
Donc, tous les croyants sont les bienvenus chez nous. Mais c'est vrai qu'on fait partie des derniers à être,
je crois, assez cohérents et actifs sur la neutralité des services publics, sur aussi quelque chose que— la neutralité et la laïcité, ça doit pas être que des interdictions, sinon effectivement, c'est un message difficile à faire passer.
On a toujours : « Oui, pourquoi vous voulez embêter ces femmes ? » Non, c'est pas ça. Il y a aussi des choses, c'est pour préserver une atmosphère et les droits, notamment des plus faibles.
Mais il y a aussi des choses positives et je cite un exemple positif dans leur expression, c'est le cours commun que moi, je voudrais voir à deux heures de philosophie et de citoyenneté et de religion.
Moi, je voudrais que dans toutes les écoles du pays, il y ait deux heures de cours qui soient axées non seulement sur
la citoyenneté et l'apprentissage de la philosophie, mais sur l'histoire des religions et qu'on arrête de ségréguer les enfants selon les convictions de leurs parents pour qu'ils aient des cours de religion
juive, islamique, catholique ou de morale et qu'à la fin de son cursus, tout étudiant soit capable de savoir qui est Socrate ou Platon ou Aristote, ce serait bien, mais aussi ce que sont les cinq piliers de l'islam, l'Évangile,
le Yom Kippour, quelques enseignements bouddhistes ou du Tao.
Moi, je trouve, c'est le bagage commun de l'humanité et ça aiderait peut-être à dénouer un certain nombre de malentendus identitaires que nous voyons surgir dans l'actualité politique.
Vous parliez de la laïcité, la neutralité dans le cadre des services publics. Et j'allais justement arriver sur l'enseignement qui, en Belgique, comme vous le savez, est très largement catholique.
La majorité des Belges sont passés par l'enseignement catholique. Je sais pas si c'est votre cas aussi.
Non.
Non ? Bah voilà, moi, c'est mon cas. J'ai fait l'entièreté de ma scolarité dans l'enseignement catholique. Du coup, si on exige la neutralité des services publics, est-ce qu'on exige la laïcisation des écoles ?
Alors, DéFI n'est pas favorable à la réouverture d'une guerre scolaire.
Personne n'est favorable à ça. Mais admettez qu'il y a quand même une contradiction.
Oui, oui, mais allez, les écoles catholiques, qu'est-ce qu'elles ont encore ? Je vais être un peu provocant. Qu'est-ce qu'elles ont encore de vraiment catholique ?
On sait tous que ce sont des très bonnes écoles.
J'ai eu des cours de la part de nonnes.
Ah ben, très bien. Et c'est vrai. Et c'est vrai aussi. On cherchait une école pour mon petit garçon et on est quand même tombés dans un institut où il y avait une bénédiction des cartables.
Donc, il reste des choses un peu folkloriques. Mais convenons, parce que c'est quand même de l'enseignement subventionné par l'État et qui, à part pour les cours de religion, déploie un programme approuvé par l'État.
Et on sent bien quand même qu'il y a une forme de lissage qui fait que, à part vos nonnes et mes cartables et deux, trois autres éléments, et ici, notamment, les cours de religion dont on a parlé, globalement,
le contenu de l'enseignement sur les autres matières est relativement semblable.
Ce sont des écoles qui sont même vues comme ayant en général plus de moyens et étant un peu plus bourgeoises et que clairement, vous n'êtes pas, c'est un enseignement financé par les pouvoirs publics, et que vous n'êtes pas dans
une école privée catholique comme elle pourrait l'être en France avec
un enseignement traditionaliste.
Donc c'est autre chose. Et là, je pense qu'on doit aller, on peut appeler ça comme on veut, vers plus de travail interréseau, qu'il soit plus facile pour des professeurs
qui ont été formés dans un réseau de pouvoir aller vers l'autre, qu'il y ait une mobilité.
Mais aussi, peut-être aussi, simplement sans aller jusqu'à un réseau unique,
on voit chaque jour des mises en commun qui n'ont pas lieu simplement parce que les écoles n'appartiennent pas au même réseau, que ce soit un hall sportif ou que ce soit...
Et ça, c'est dommage. Donc, à mon avis, on peut casser gentiment les vieux réflexes de réseau là où ils existent encore sans avoir à refaire une guerre scolaire.
Parce que, à part quelques éléments folkloriques et liés au projet d'école,
sincèrement, je crois que la manière d'enseigner le contenu des cours, maintenant, on le voit bien, les parents et même les étudiants, quand il s'agit de choisir après dans leur cursus dans l'enseignement supérieur,
pourquoi est-ce qu'on choisit une université ou pourquoi est-ce qu'on choisit une école ?
La proximité, la qualité des cours.
Mmm-hmm.
Le reste, si une matière est mieux enseignée à l'ULB, on va aller à l'ULB. Si elle est mieux enseignée à l'UCL, on va aller à l'UCL.
Et on sent bien que les clivages d'antan—
La polarisation.
La polarisation a perdu une partie de son intérêt, globalement.
Oui. Donc, vous dites que la qualité de l'enseignement et les matières enseignées sont sensiblement les mêmes, qu'on soit dans l'enseignement catholique ou l'enseignement—
Alors, c'est difficile de nier que
l'enseignement catholique libre a,
a globalement meilleure réputation que l'enseignement officiel et de l'État, même s'il y a aussi de très bonnes écoles, notamment communales et même du réseau de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Est-ce que c'est dû à l'autonomie de ces écoles ?
Est-ce que c'est dû au quartier où ces écoles sont implantées ? Je n'en ai aucune idée. Je ne suis pas expert des réseaux d'enseignement.
Ce que je sais, c'est qu'il faut aller vers un décloisonnement intelligent sans rallumer de guerres scolaires.
Mmm-hmm. Je veux juste pointer du doigt que de fait, mon prof de sciences était aussi mon prof de religion.
Ah voilà. Bah... Mais en fait, pourquoi pas ?
Il n'y a pas si longtemps, hein.
Non, non, mais ça, c'est intéressant. Oui, il y a une sorte de tradition logique. Beaucoup de philosophes, c'était le cas des Grecs notamment,
ceux qui réfléchissaient sur l'organisation du monde et ceux qui testaient des hypothèses scientifiques étaient les mêmes.
Puis au Moyen Âge, les religieux et les philosophes étaient aussi les mêmes. Tous les autres étaient au champ ou à la guerre, de toute façon.
Donc voilà, il y a une certaine—
Il était créationniste.
Il était créationniste, votre prof ?
Oui, tout à fait. Celui qui donnait sciences et religion.
Ah, ça devait être formidable d'avoir un cours de sciences de la part d'un créationniste.
Écoutez, mais parce que là, vous me disiez que sensiblement, la matière, la façon d'enseigner—
Ah mais c'est une information que vous me donnez. Je suis limite choqué.
C'était à Mater Dei à Woluwe-Saint-Pierre.
Excellente commune par ailleurs, mais j'en prends note.
Très bien. Mais donc, toujours sur la question de la laïcité, vous vous êtes exprimé il y a pas longtemps, vous avez fait cette déclaration.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai dit encore ?
Vous avez dit : « Ecolo est le relais de l'islam politique. »
Ah oui, j'ai dit ça.
Alors, Jean-Luc Crucke, Zakia Khattabi et d'autres figures politiques ont commenté en exprimant que c'était une parole extrêmement malheureuse.
Alors, plein de questions, plein de commentaires ont été faits à ce sujet-là. Je vais simplement vous poser la question très directement.
Est-ce que cette déclaration était empreinte d'islamophobie ? Est-ce que cette déclaration était empreinte d'électoralisme ?
Ni l'un ni l'autre. Alors,
comme je passe pour un jeune homme relativement modéré dans ses expressions, dès que je dis quelque chose d'un peu plus violent, on me demande de répéter dix fois la phrase et à chaque fois, ça rebondit.
Mmm-hmm.
Donc, je peux répéter que Ecolo est régulièrement le relais de l'islam politique. Chaque mot est pesé dans cette déclaration.
J'ai parlé de relais. Le relais n'est pas l'identification. Et j'ai parlé d'islam politique et non pas d'islamisme. Ce que j'entends par là, c'est que dans toute une série de leurs prises de position, que ce soit de manière
consciente pour certains ou naïve pour beaucoup d'entre eux, il y a le relais chez Ecolo d'une phraséologie qui vise à implémenter un programme d'islam politique.
L'islam politique, c'est pas l'islamisme. L'islam politique, c'est une doctrine qui a le temps pour elle et dont l'objectif est de rendre nos sociétés occidentales les plus conformes possible
à l'accueil d'un islam rigoriste, même si ça doit prendre une génération ou deux.
Évidemment qu'ils ne vont pas commencer par les sujets les plus intouchables. Jamais vous n'allez voir l'islam politique attaquer aujourd'hui l'avortement, par exemple.
Par contre, la neutralité de l'État, ça, c'est un sujet fragile en Belgique. Et donc on va vous expliquer, par exemple, que la neutralité de l'État, telle qu'elle impose
une neutralité d'apparence aux fonctionnaires, qu'ils soient contractuels ou statutaires, eh bien, c'est tout de même un petit peu islamophobe et c'est au minimum discriminatoire.
Dire ça, c'est être le relais, par exemple, de l'islam politique. Dire que les techniques d'abattage en Wallonie, il n'y a pas de souci, la souffrance animale doit être préservée, mais qu'à Bruxelles, on ne sait pas pourquoi,
eh bien, il faut continuer
à abattre des bêtes sans étourdissement et à les égorger absolument parce qu'un rite religieux le demande, alors que l'étourdissement est une méthode qui a été inventée en plus pour respecter les rites religieux et les combiner au bien-être animal,
c'est se faire le relais de l'islam politique.
Quand madame Jenot distribue un tract sur le marché de Laeken en listant tous les partis selon la manière dont ils implémentent ou non les satisfactions d'un programme religieux,
elle montre qu'il y a une frange, encore, je vais être très précis, c'est une frange, une petite frange d'écolos, mais qui est malheureusement influente parce que l'islam politique, il compte sur des relais, pas que chez Écolo d'ailleurs,
politiques, associatifs, académiques et c'est un mouvement qui a le temps pour lui.
C'est comme ça. Ça veut pas dire que tous les écolos comprennent exactement ce qui se passe. Je crois que c'est pas le cas.
Je crois qu'il y a des tas d'écologistes qui pensent sincèrement que lutter contre la neutralité telle qu'elle existe, c'est un projet émancipateur et de lutte contre les discriminations et qui ne voient pas le problème.
Mais ils sont malheureusement, je pense, ceux-là, les idiots utiles d'un projet qui va au-delà d'eux.
Donc c'est une déclaration qui avait fait suite à un vote au sein de la commune de Anderlecht, si je ne me trompe pas. Vote auquel a également, par exemple, participé le PTB.
Oui.
Vous avez choisi de cibler Ecolo spécifiquement dans votre déclaration.
Parce que c'est Ecolo qui était à la manœuvre.
D'accord.
C'est une échevine écologiste qui a déposé le projet. Et ça, c'est le dernier ingrédient qui permet de parler d'islam politique.
C'est le côté, il y a un moment où il faut aller dans une forme de transgression, comme à la STIB, où Ecolo, avec l'aide du PS, a empêché, c'est quand même dingue, il y a quatre ans, la STIB—
D'aller en appel d'un jugement qui les condamnait pour discrimination.
De la même manière, à Anderlecht, ce qu'ils ont tenté, c'est un rapport de force contre nous. On est quand même dans la majorité à Anderlecht, donc on se sentait un peu concernés.
Avec une majorité alternative incluant le PTB, qui est quand même l'extrême gauche, jusqu'à preuve du contraire, donc rompant avec une forme de cordon
démocratique avec ce parti pour imposer une position sur des signes convictionnels dans l'administration.
Dès le moment où il y a un coup de force, pas sur n'importe quel sujet, hein, ça n'arrive que sur ce sujet-là, vous pouvez vous dire : là, y a un problème et on est dans le relais d'une pensée, d'un lobby qui dépasse autre chose.
Il faut voir les menaces qu'ont reçu les conseillers communaux et même notre échevin à l'époque.
Mh.
Il a reçu des menaces de mort. Il y avait des— vous aviez des petites figurines qui circulaient sur Internet.
Vous regardiez le nom de la personne, ils sont partis et en mode : on surveille ce que tu vas voter.
On n'imagine pas le climat ambiant qui s'installe malheureusement dans certains quartiers de Bruxelles sur ces questions.
C'est pas un détail, c'est pas d'islamophobie parce que notre position, elle touche toutes les religions, convictions sur la neutralité de la même manière.
Je dis juste qu'il y a une forme d'islam politique qui essaie de trouver des alliés là où il peut et qui l'en trouve notamment, mais pas seulement aujourd'hui, chez Écolo.
Hum, alors, vous avez bien insisté sur le mot relais. Donc est-ce que il faut comprendre que c'est donc simplement de l'opportunisme, de l'électoralisme ?
On saisit une opportunité puisqu'il y a une population musulmane importante à Bruxelles. Ou est-ce que, au sein du parti lui-même, vous estimez qu'il y a des positions radicales d'islam politique ?
Alors, y a trois partis qui ont cette tentation communautariste. C'est assez clair, c'est le PTB, le PS et Écolo pour des motifs différents.
Je crois que le PS est profondément un parti laïc, mais qui a fait un calcul cynique qu'il fallait-
Il y a une élue qui a changé de parti, qui est passée du PS vers Écolo, j'ai oublié son nom malheureusement, parce qu'on lui a demandé sur le portrait officiel, sur la photo, de ne pas porter de foulard.
Ah oui ? Voilà, intéressant.
Et donc, elle avait le droit chez Écolo.
Mais le PS bruxellois a quand même fait un calcul cynique de relatif abandon de la laïcité.
Mh.
Mais on assume que c'est une forme de cynisme, que voilà, dans les quartiers, voilà, ça ne sert plus à rien d'être laïc.
Chez Écolo, il y a une part de conviction. C'est tout là, c'est tout l'intérêt et c'est tout le problème aussi. C'est que y a vraiment chez eux, dans cette atmosphère,
et pourtant, j'ai travaillé, moi, dans le secteur de lutte contre les discriminations, donc je me sens légitime à en parler.
Dans cette atmosphère,
que toute contrainte
de non-port d'un signe convictionnel est nécessairement une discrimination et une violence, il y a quand même cette idée qu'il y a une philosophie là-derrière qui justifie la lutte contre une forme de neutralité.
Moi, je pense que considérer la neutralité comme discriminatoire, c'est irresponsable et que ça nous mène très loin.
Mais c'est plus justifié dans leur projet, y a aucun cynisme. C'est pour ça que je parle de,
de relais. Il y a aussi, chez beaucoup d'écologistes, une intention louable de lutte contre les discriminations et ils ne comprennent pas de quoi ils sont les relais.
Donc vous avez expliqué tout à l'heure que vous avez d'habitude tendance à avoir des propos modérés, sages, doux, et que là, ça avait particulièrement choqué puisque ça se démarquait de vos propos habituels.
On a des amis en commun. On m'a expliqué que vous étiez quelqu'un de très intelligent. Donc je suis sûr qu'en faisant cette déclaration publiquement dans la presse, vous avez conscience que c'était des propos assez explosifs.
Est-ce que vous avez conscience que des propos comme ça ont... Voilà, y a un certain risque qui est encouru de réveiller des tensions communautaires, des peurs et de l'islamophobie au sein de la population ?
Parce que quand on entend les propos comme ça, on-- quand au sein de la population, on lit, on entend des propos comme celui-là, on peut éventuellement réveiller certains relents.
Il y a deux écoles dans votre question
sous-jacente sur ces problèmes. Il y a l'idée de dire : « Ouh là là », ce qui est un peu ce qu'on nous serine depuis trente ans, « y a des sujets dont il faut surtout pas parler parce qu'on va réveiller
des peurs, des colères, des ressentiments et donc n'en parlons pas ».
Et n'en parlons tellement pas que finalement, ce sont des cours et des tribunaux ou de temps en temps un règlement d'ordre intérieur qui vont amener les sujets et mettre le feu aux poudres.
Et donc, ne légiférons pas sur la neutralité, ni sur l'école, ni sur quoi que ce soit d'autre.
Dans ce cas-ci, disons que vos propos ont été réduits à une phrase. Je sais pas s'il y avait beaucoup de choses derrière ou si-
Si, y avait des phrases avant, y avait des phrases après.
Oui, oui, voilà, c'est ça. Mais donc-
Évidemment. Ça, c'est malheureusement le jeu médiatique. Peut-être que vous ferez une promo de ce podcast où vous réduirez aussi à deux, trois phrases.
Ça, c'est-- Et on doit malheureusement, nous, hommes et femmes politiques, jouer avec ça et c'est parfois compliqué.
Mais je suis pas naïf. En lançant cette phrase, même en parlant de baba au rhum avant et de relativité Einstein après, je savais que c'était cette phrase-là qu'on prendrait.
Donc je l'assume et je peux pas ne pas
assumer ses conséquences. Mais je pense qu'il est quand même permis
de parler d'islam politique, de parler de neutralité ou de laïcité sans avoir à continuellement devoir endurer le reproche : « Mais quand même, en en parlant, est-ce que vous ne reprovoquez pas quelque chose ?
» Si on n'en parle pas, si on n'en parle jamais, il finit par arriver ce qui arrive, c'est-à-dire un jugement qui condamne la STIB, qui condamne l'Actiris,
qui se-- Et le-- vous avez un politique qui démissionne complètement de ces sujets-là, comme il démissionne des questions de migration pour la même raison, parce que c'est compliqué que dès le moment où on commence à y entrer
sans pouvoir donner de mesures claires, ben on se fait taxer de complicité du jeu des extrêmes.
Moi, je crois que ce que ça finit par donner, c'est des thèmes comme Charles de Gaulle et la laïcité récupérés en France par le Rassemblement national, ce qui est à pleurer.
Alors que ce sont des-- la laïcité est un sujet de gauche, être gaulliste, c'est de droite sociale, républicaine.
C'est malheureusement en ne traitant pas des sujets qu'on finit par les laisser aux extrêmes. Et donc moi, je préfère que les démocrates osent,
même durement entre eux, parce que c'est jamais que du-- c'est du combat politique, c'est donc de l'échange de mots,
osent se dire les choses en face. J'en ai déjà discuté avec Zakia Khattabi et avec d'autres.
Très bien, débattons. Je vais expliquer pourquoi, chère Zakia, je pense, même inconsciemment, que pour une large partie d'entre vous, que vous êtes le relais de quelque chose de dangereux.
Et voici pourquoi. Parlons-en. Ils vont me dire que... Je trouve qu'il n'y a pas de débat dont il faut avoir peur en démocratie.
Et le côté : « Ouh là là, il ne faut pas en parler parce que ça va alimenter. » Non, là, désolé. Sauf s'il s'agit vraiment de choses dont tout le monde doit s'abstenir, à savoir évidemment des incitations à la haine, évidemment
des accusations diffamantes contre d'autres personnes.
Jamais attaquer les personnes elles-mêmes, mais les idées, elles sont tout sauf inattaquables. Vous avez le droit de vous attaquer en politique à n'importe quelle idée, elles sont là pour ça.
Dans la continuation de cette idée-là, on a évoqué tout à l'heure le nom de Caroline Fourest. Est-ce que vous partagez, par exemple, ses positions ?
En quoi l'islamophobie, c'est un concept malheureux ? Ou bien est-ce que vous reconnaissez que c'est tout à fait avéré ?
Je reconnais que des gens sont discriminés comme musulmans. C'est indéniable.
Quelqu'un qu'on laisse pas entrer, je sais pas moi, dans un bar parce qu'elle porte un signe convictionnel comme un hijab, ça, il y a quelque chose qui est de la haine envers les personnes selon leurs convictions religieuses, ça existe.
J'aime pas le mot islamophobie.
D'accord. Pourquoi ?
D'abord parce qu'il a été inventé par les ayatollahs iraniens. En septante-neuf, le régime théocratique iranien,
qui est quand même le premier épisode d'islam politique réalisé
au XXᵉ siècle, réellement, a inventé le terme d'islamophobie pour culpabiliser les Occidentaux et pour les mettre en miroir par rapport à leur population musulmane et créer une forme de ressort.
Je n'aime pas le mot islamophobie parce qu'il amalgame des choses différentes. Vous pouvez tout à fait ne pas aimer l'islam, c'est votre droit, tout comme vous pouvez ne pas aimer la religion catholique ou n'importe quel corpus de pensée.
Ce n'est pas parce que vous n'aimez pas que vous avez un sentiment de haine et vous allez discriminer qui que ce soit. Or, c'est ce que, en amalgamant le mot phobie et le mot islam, vous laissez penser tout de même
que ne pas aimer l'islam est un problème.
Non, vous pouvez ne pas aimer n'importe quel corpus, la philosophie grecque, ce n'est pas un souci. Deux : qu'est-ce qui est islamophobe ?
Neuf fois sur dix, ce n'est pas compliqué. C'est les administrations ou les employeurs qui, toujours pour de mauvaises raisons, entre guillemets, pensent ceux qui croient que l'islamophobie est un terme juste,
réglementent la neutralité de leur administration publique ou de leur entreprise contre les musulmans.
Ce n'est pas contre les musulmans. Une loi n'est pas islamophobe, par exemple, si elle s'applique de la même manière à tous les signes convictionnels, quels qu'ils soient.
Et donc, je trouve qu'il y a une instrumentalisation de ce mot islamophobie qui fait qu'honnêtement, je m'en méfie tout en reconnaissant qu'il manque peut-être un mot et que bien sûr, comme c'est le cas pour d'autres religions,
des gens sont discriminés, par ailleurs, de manière injuste, sur base de leur appartenance religieuse.
Mais une femme qui se voit refuser un emploi parce qu'elle porte un foulard dans une administration publique n'est pas victime de discrimination et encore moins d'islamophobie parce qu'elle
est supposée se soumettre à la neutralité de l'État qui met toutes les convictions religieuses au même plan.
Et là, il y a une instrumentalisation qui me paraît être un piège. Et là, je rejoins Caroline Fourest.
Dernière question sur cette déclaration. Est-ce que ça a été bien reçu, bien vécu au sein de DéFI ou bien est-ce qu'il y a eu débat ?
Vous voyez peut-être régulièrement qu'on débatte au sein de DéFI, mais alors pour le coup, sur ce jeu-là, pas du tout. Il y a un consensus extrêmement large sur le sujet.
Nous sommes très unis sur la question.
Ok, c'est très clair. Alors, on a eu l'occasion de parler un petit peu de philosophie. On a longuement parlé de laïcité.
On va maintenant parler d'un troisième sujet qui vous est cher. Est-ce que vous voyez de quoi je veux parler ?
Non.
Olivier Maingain.
Oui, très bien. Parlons-en.
On va revenir sur ce qui se passe dernièrement au sein de DéFI. Pour rappel des faits, il y a eu un congrès à l'ULB récemment pour définir les listes électorales, puisque c'est comme ça que fonctionne DéFI,
de manière extrêmement démocratique, même au sein du parti.
Plusieurs listes ont été proposées. Le camp d'Olivier Maingain défendait certaines listes. Vous défendiez vous-même plutôt d'autres listes.
Il y a eu un vote. Il faut 60 % pour se mettre d'accord. Les 60 % ont été obtenus. Et puis, un de vos conseils a pris l'initiative de faire un recomptage des voix.
Et apparemment, dix non ont été erronément comptés comme étant des oui, ce qui a permis d'atteindre cette majorité de 60 %.
Mais une fois l'erreur constatée et corrigée, cette majorité absolue n'était pas atteinte. Alors Olivier Maingain, évidemment, est entré dans une rage.
Évidemment. Non, pas évidemment. Il n'y avait aucune raison d'entrer dans une rage.
Disons que c'est dans son caractère. Il est entré dans une certaine rage, une certaine ire. Il a choisi de le faire publiquement.
Ça, ce n'est pas évident, par contre. Il a choisi de le faire publiquement dans les médias. Il a menacé de quitter le parti.
Il a accusé le conseil en question d'un certain antisémitisme en allant chercher des vieux posts Facebook de 2012. Ce n'est pas non plus évident, mais il a choisi de le faire.
Comment ça va entre vous et Olivier Maingain ? Comment ça va chez DéFI ?
Je vais faire une réponse circonstanciée, mais je peux dire le jour qu'elle nous enregistre aujourd'hui, je ne sais pas quand vous serez diffusé et les choses qui se seront peut-être passées d'ici là.
C'est vrai. Ça sera dans deux semaines, je pense.
Dans deux semaines. Peut-être que la crise sera résolue ou que ce sera aggravé. C'est pour l'instant imprévisible. Non, c'est une séquence complètement folle.
On enregistre donc le 27 février.
Oui, très bien. Le 27 février, je peux dire que cette séquence est complètement folle et j'espère qu'on en sortira. Plusieurs choses.
D'abord, une chose importante à rappeler, et merci d'avoir dit, mais je vais quand même l'expliciter, tout ceci arrive parce que DéFI est une démocratie.
Il n'y a pas d'autres partis à part Écolo. Vous voyez, je peux être gentil. Écolo est un parti extrêmement démocratique aussi.
Pour le reste, dans les autres partis, c'est en général le président et quelques personnes qui composent les listes. Vous n'aurez jamais de problème de recomptage au PS ou MR parce que les militants ne votent pas sur les listes.
Chez DéFI, effectivement, il faut 60 % des voix. Deux, toujours, c'est la liste, les autres listes ont été approuvées sans problème.
C'est la liste régionale bruxelloise qui concentre
Généralement, les tensions, parce que c'est là qu'apparaissent des logiques parfois de clans, de luttes entre sections, de luttes entre influences, entre les députés sortants et ceux qui voudraient bien le devenir,
de questions de gestion de la diversité qui est encore un sujet qui doit être en progrès chez nous, on va le dire franchement.
Quand vous dites diversité, vous parlez de ?
Bah les personnes d'origine étrangère, DéFI, malheureusement. Alors ici, en arrivant, vous n'avez peut-être croisé que des personnes-
Racisées, on peut le dire.
Ouais ou racisées, de couleur. Il faut aussi parler du mot racisé.
Je savais, je savais que vous ne vouliez pas le dire, mais...
Vous êtes toujours racisé par quelqu'un, donc c'est... Mais bref, on a fait des énormes-- en termes d'employés, y a pas de souci, mais en termes d'élus, on a un peu de retard et c'est parfois difficile de pousser ce
vieux parti, surtout encore très fort dans les, dans l'est et le sud de Bruxelles, à aller au bout de la démarche.
Et donc c'est-- je dis ça parce que ça a fait partie du débat qui a eu lieu le dimanche 18. C'est notamment la place de diversité.
Y a pas eu plusieurs listes. Y a-- la commission électorale s'amène avec une première liste. On discute, ça va pas, machin, on change ceci, on essaie de la faire passer au vote.
La première version de la liste a recueilli seulement cinquante-cinq pour cent des voix. Et il se trouve qu'en effet, une deuxième version de la liste, après sept ou huit heures de débat, c'est important parce que ça fait partie du problème,
et un comptage fait sans doute, parce que j'étais là, j'ai pas participé au comptage, mais je peux témoigner qu'une erreur est plausible lors du comptage, arrive à un résultat qui passe avec soixante pour cent des voix plus une.
Vous, vous alliez-- vous n'avez pas tout à fait terminé votre phrase. Vous allez faire un commentaire sur le comptage des voix qui était ?
Qui était pénible, laborieux, un peu pressé et un peu fait par des personnes fatiguées-
D'accord.
Qui doivent gérer la tension humaine de gens qui, de l'autre côté de la porte, donnent l'impression qu'ils vont jouer leur vie parce qu'ils jouent, pour certains, peut-être leur carrière selon leur place qui se trouve sur une liste.
Tout ça crée une atmosphère qui était pas simple à gérer. Et ben alors, il se trouve que la liste, votée à une voix près, c'est vrai, je le vois tout de suite, sonne quand même comme une douche froide dans l'Assemblée.
Y a des-- parce que ça met en jeu toute une série de députés qui n'ont pourtant pas démérité.
Donc c'est une liste, peut-être qu'elle, toutes les listes possibles qui font soixante pour cent des voix chez DéFI aujourd'hui
seront comme ça, mais c'est une liste qui, je le vois, crée quand même une fracture dans le parti, mais soit.
On la proclame. Bah merci, au revoir. Je fais quand même un message en disant : bah c'est, on a quand même vécu une drôle de journée, il va falloir réparer un certain nombre de fractures.
Et puis on repart, on repart tous chez nous. On a un bureau le lendemain politique à Wavre, où mon chef de cabinet est d'ailleurs là.
On a remballé d'abord la veille, ça se passait à l'ULB, les enveloppes, les bulletins, tout, tout en les préservant dans des contenants.
Et il se trouve que le lendemain après-midi, le lundi dix-neuf, pas pour le plaisir de recompter et pas pour le plaisir de vérifier quoi que ce soit comme j'ai entendu, mais pour pouvoir établir un procès-verbal.
Mon directeur de cabinet, qui est l'un des hommes les plus honnêtes que je connaisse, se met ici, dans le bureau d'à côté, à ouvrir l'enveloppe.
Et parce qu'il n'a plus en tête, parce que Didier Gosuin, le président de la commission électorale, a simplement oralement promulgué, ben, qu'y a cent quarante voix, une abstention, autant de oui, autant de non.
Il a plus, moi non plus, je l'ai plus en mémoire. Plus personne ne l'a, à part Didier Gosuin et son petit papier.
Plus personne n'a ça. On sait que le oui est passé, mais on ne sait plus de combien. Donc simplement, il recompte pour avoir le nombre total de voix, de oui et de non.
Et là, il s'aperçoit que là, y a un problème parce que la proportion soixante/quarante semble ne pas y être. Il appelle tout de suite le directeur du centre d'études, qui est aussi le secrétaire de la commission électorale.
Ils recomptent à deux. Alors, ils le font à trois. Il voit qu'y a un problème. Alors, peut-être qu'on n'a pas tous les bulletins.
Ils appellent, ils m'appellent moi, je leur dis : contactez Didier Gosuin, qui lui, connaît sûrement de mémoire le nombre de bulletins et a toujours ses notes.
Didier Gosuin nous envoie un mail genre c'est cent quarante bulletins avec autant de oui, autant de non. Alors, on a bien cent quarante bulletins, mais on n'a pas les mêmes oui, on n'a pas les mêmes non.
On a une différence de dix oui d'un côté, de dix non de l'autre. Ce qui, nécessairement, puisqu'il y a bien cent quarante bulletins, induit qu'il y a une erreur de comptage la veille, puisqu'ils ont compté ça par tas de dix.
C'est le fait que ce soit une différence de dix d'un côté, dix de l'autre qui accrédite cela. Pour être sûr, on va aussi chercher les bulletins vierges qu'on avait aussi gardés, parce qu'on avait fait des tirages de cinq cent bulletins.
Chaque scrutin avait sa couleur. Il reste pile trois cent soixante bulletins. Ça veut dire qu'avec les cent quarante, ça colle.
Ça veut dire qu'au-delà de tout doute raisonnable, on se retrouve avec un scrutin qui n'est pas celui que nous avions proclamé.
Que devait faire mon directeur de cabinet ? Est-ce qu'il devait garder ça pour lui ? Je pense pas. Je pense que là, il aurait commis une faute.
Il a alerté la chaîne de commandement, c'est-à-dire moi-même, le secrétaire général, la commission électorale. La commission électorale s'est réunie le lundi soir,
a décidé, bon alors, c'est embêtant, mais on trouve pas d'autre chose à faire que de revoter cette liste.
La commission électorale aurait pu dire : on en vote directement une autre. Non non, on va revoter la même liste.
Et c'est alors que de manière complètement inexplicable, le lendemain, Olivier Maingain fait une conférence de presse incendiaire sans posséder aucun élément.
Il connaît pas l'histoire des bulletins, il sait pas combien y en a, il est pas venu les voir lui-même, pour accuser mon collaborateur et donc moi-même de tricherie. C'est sale-
Et votre collaborateur en particulier, il ne l'aime vraiment pas. Il a vraiment des-
C'est le moins, c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Un rapport personnel avec lui qui est...
Bah on est dans quelque chose de complètement irrationnel, d'un peu suicidaire et de scandaleux parce qu'il porte des accusations extrêmement graves, diffamantes, sans apporter le moindre élément de preuve.
Et c'est désolant parce que d'abord, mon collaborateur, sa famille ne méritent absolument pas ça. Il n'a fait aucune faute.
Et le parti a fait exactement ce qu'il devait faire et on gérait ça complètement en interne. On allait de façon donc nécessairement reconvoquer un conseil général sur le sujet,
jusqu'à ce qu'Olivier, pour des raisons qui sont incompréhensibles, décide de mettre le feu.
Ça change rien au fait que la procédure devra aller jusqu'à son terme. On va faire revoter cette liste. Si elle atteint loyalement, normalement, les soixante pour cent, y a aucun problème.
Ce sera notre liste, et je la soutiendrai. Si elle les atteint pas, il faudra reproposer une autre liste, mais on ne pouvait pas partir aux élections avec une liste qui n'a pas de légitimité démocratique.
Quant aux propos... Et là non plus, je ne comprends pas Olivier, et j'espère vraiment qu'il va revenir à quelque chose de plus rationnel et vraisemblable.
Aller chercher des déclarations de n'importe qui... c'est, on pourrait le faire avec moi, avec n'importe qui d'autre, d'il y a douze, treize ans, les isoler de leur contexte.
Cardinal, je crois que c'est Richelieu, disait : « Donnez-moi six lignes du plus honnête des hommes, je vous le fais pendre. »
C'est facile et ça n'a pas de sens. Olivier Maingain, en 2007, il a traité Yves Leterme d'autiste. Est-ce que je vais aller prendre cette phrase pour
expliquer qu'il a le mépris des gens qui souffrent du trouble autistique alors qu'évidemment, ce n'est pas le cas ?
Ou je pourrais l'incendier sur des... prendre trois déclarations vigoureuses de lui contre le nationalisme flamand et essayer de le faire passer pour un raciste anti-Flamand, ce qu'il n'est évidemment pas.
Donc, je crois qu'Olivier vaut beaucoup mieux que ça. Il est évidemment fâché qu'une liste qu'il aimait beaucoup soit remise en cause, mais moi, c'est pas mon problème.
Mon problème, c'est d'avoir une liste quelle qu'elle soit, qui soit
statutairement légitime. L'erreur a été découverte fortuitement et elle ne provient pas de mon collaborateur, elle provient de la commission électorale où visiblement, un tas de dix a été compté du mauvais côté.
C'est bête, ça arrive. La démocratie, c'est ça aussi, mais il faut corriger l'erreur. On ne peut pas partir avec une liste qui n'a pas la correcte légitimité démocratique.
Je vais simplement déjà revenir sur un premier détail, puisque Didier Gosuin a également fait une sortie médiatique.
Et là, j'avoue que je suis un petit peu perdu puisque vous l'avez présenté en revenant sur les faits comme le président de la commission électorale.
Et si je ne m'abuse, dans les médias, il a expliqué qu'il ne l'est plus depuis longtemps-
Alors-
...et qu'il a quitté cette fonction précisément parce qu'il avait vu venir tout ça.
C'est plus compliqué que ça. Didier, que j'apprécie beaucoup,
a souhaité quitter la commission électorale
au début décembre parce qu'une proposition qu'il avait faite à un des candidats n'a pas été relevée, n'a pas été prise par ce candidat, mais il a continué à faire partie de la commission électorale et a présidé les séances.
Donc, on peut jouer sur les mots, mais c'est bien lui qui présidait la séance de la commission électorale le jour du conseil général.
Mais voilà, franchement, c'est du détail. Je crois que pour le reste, il serait assez d'accord avec mon récit des événements.
Ok, ok. L'image de DéFI dans tout ça, je suis désolé de vous le dire, c'est assez amateur, assez chaotique. À quelques mois des élections, est-ce que vous ne craignez pas des conséquences électorales, concrètement ?
Elles sont à craindre si les électeurs ne regardent que ça, mais on a aussi un programme, on a du contenu. Et puis surtout, on a notre sincérité et notre authenticité.
Des électeurs de DéFI savent bien qui nous sommes, c'est-à-dire des démocrates, une démocratie où parfois les portes claquent, mais où les portes sont solides, avec des caractères forts.
Ben voilà, ça fait partie de nous. Moi, je préfère faire partie d'un parti relativement modeste, avec une engueulade de temps en temps, même si là, des mots forts, trop forts ont été utilisés,
qu'un grand parti avec tout le monde le doigt sur la couture du pantalon et où personne ne demande l'avis des militants quand on fait venir Marc Izsa ou Julie Tatont.
Vous voyez, l'un dans l'autre, c'est pas si mal.
L'image d'un Olivier Maingain qui règle ses comptes sur Twitter, est-ce que c'est porteur électoralement ?
Bien sûr que non et c'est dommage. Et donc j'espère, moi, en tout cas, je m'abstiens de toute,
désormais, de tout remue-ménage médiatique et j'espère que lui aussi va retrouver calme et sérénité et nous aider à, ah ben, à aller vers la solution.
Parce que malgré les excès de ces derniers jours, je garde une vraie estime sincère pour Olivier. On a besoin de lui et de son expertise.
On a moins besoin de ses départs d'incendie. Il y a à mon avis moyen de garder l'un et de se passer de l'autre.
Et donc je l'invite à revenir dans la famille.
Je vais faire le lien avec un autre événement où vous vous alliez avec Olivier Maingain il y a quelque temps, je me souviens plus exactement de la date.
C'était au moment des rencontres entre Jean-Luc Crucke et l'ancien CDH, ce qui allait devenir Les Engagés, et était convié autour de la table un représentant pour DéFI.
Ça n'a pas été vous. Ça s'est fait apparemment derrière votre dos, en secret. C'était avec Olivier Maingain. Comment est-ce que vous avez vécu ça ?
Parce qu'en fait, voilà, les
les événements qu'on vient d'évoquer et cet événement-là donnent un petit peu l'impression qu'Olivier Maingain se considère, est considéré visiblement par autrui, un petit peu comme le parrain, le godfather de DéFI.
Alors-
C'est lui qui décide un petit peu dans l'ombre et que c'est lui qu'il faut consulter quand on veut travailler avec DéFI.
C'est un petit peu l'image que ça renvoie, en tout cas.
S'il y a crise aujourd'hui, c'est justement parce que ce n'est pas le cas. De un. De deux-
Et est-ce que c'est le cas dans son esprit ?
De deux, sur... il faudrait lui demander. Je vous laisse votre interprétation. Dans le cas que vous évoquez,
ils ont été chercher expressément Olivier parce qu'ils avaient identifié Olivier comme la cause de l'échec d'un rapprochement entre DéFI et le CDH la fois d'avant, ce qui n'est pas complètement faux.
Et ils se sont dit : « Bah, pour contourner l'obstacle, on a Jean-Luc. Tout ce monde-là se connaît parce qu'ils sont en politique depuis plus longtemps que moi.
On va d'abord sonder Olivier Maingain puisqu'apparemment, c'est lui qui fait obstacle. » C'est la seule raison pour laquelle ils l'ont fait.
J'ai été convié extrêmement vite après. Et ça n'a pas de rapport direct avec ce qui nous occupe aujourd'hui, parce que là, pour le coup, on était tous d'accord.
On a fait une analyse au sein du parti.
D'accord sur le fait que vous n'étiez pas d'accord avec eux.
On était tous d'accord sur le fait que, ben, Les Engagés, même si moi, je salue toujours les gens qui ont le courage de se remettre en cause, de changer de nom, et d'aménager un programme.
Et il faut, ce serait malhonnête de ne pas le reconnaître. Il y a un vrai exercice qui a été fait,
mais ça reste un parti extrêmement conservateur qui nous inquiète sur une série de ses positions, que ce soit sur le nationalisme flamand, que ce soit sur la laïcité ou, ben ils ont, on parlait d'Anderlecht, la motion qui est passée
pro signes convictionnels, elle est signée notamment par Les Engagés.
Ils sont aussi beaucoup plus conservateurs que nous sur des sujets pour lesquels nous sommes très progressistes, comme le droit à l'IVG.
Et donc, ils ont abandonné soi-disant leur ADN social chrétien, mais en fait, c'est un immense coup de com' qui ne nous convainc pas.
Et on n'est pas arrivé sur les trois dossiers que je viens de vous citer à un chemin qui puisse nous convenir. Et sur ce coup-là, tous, en ce compris Olivier et moi, étions d'accord. Donc comme quoi
OK. Quand j'ai interrogé Jean-Luc Crucke à ce sujet il y a quelques semaines, donc lui, c'est marrant parce que lui, il expliquait que ce dossier-là était finalement assez anecdotique et que ce n'était pas le centre de la discorde.
Il mettait plutôt en avant le rapport avec la N-VA où eux peuvent imaginer travailler avec la N-VA alors que c'est une exclusive pour DéFI.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'il vous dise d'autre, Jean-Luc ? Il est libre penseur qui a accepté d'aller
être le porte-voix d'un parti qui reste conservateur et ancré dans ses bassins namurois et luxembourgeois, dans un électorat extrêmement conservateur et catholique.
Donc, il est obligé de vous dire et il est même obligé de le penser-
Mh.
Il est obligé de considérer que l'avortement n'est pas un sujet. Il a même proposé de le régler par référendum. Je vous avoue que je suis quand même tombé de ma chaise.
C'est un vrai sujet et le fait, l'astuce-
Il n'a pas dit que ce n'était pas un sujet. Il a toujours été, il a toujours exprimé très clairement qu'il était pour un-
Oui, mais le,
la manière dont Les Engagés ont
décidé de botter le sujet en touche en disant : « Ah, en fait, nous, on n'a plus d'avis, nous, parti politique, Les Engagés, on n'a plus d'avis sur l'avortement, c'est nos parlementaires qui décideront quoi faire. »
Le MR dit la même chose.
Exactement. Mais dans les deux cas, je trouve ça d'une hypocrisie crasse. Ça veut dire que sur les sujets peut-être les plus importants pour
ce qu'est l'humanité, ce qu'est le droit des femmes à disposer de leur corps,
les quelques centaines de femmes qui chaque jour vont toujours subir un avortement tardif aux Pays-Bas parce que la législation est toujours trop restrictive en Belgique,
eh ben, vous votez Engagés ou MR, ben, vous votez pour des partis qui n'ont pas d'avis sur la question.
Alors, c'est leur problème,
mais la clause éthique, elle me semble tellement facile. Moi, je crois qu'un parti politique, c'est là aussi pour avoir un avis sur les sujets les plus compliqués et pas juste avoir la meilleure réforme fiscale dans le pays le plus taxé du monde.
Mh.
Ce qui est fascinant, c'est que donc, je vous rejoins sur la
question de l'avortement, effectivement, DéFI sans doute de manière nettement plus apparente et progressiste sur cette question, comparé par exemple aux Engagés et comparé par exemple au Mouvement Réformateur.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que sur les questions du port du voile, vous utilisez le qualificatif de conservateur pour parler des Engagés et vous employez le terme de compatible avec l'islam politique pour parler d'Écolo.
Oui, parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas au même... ils peuvent arriver à la même destination, mais avec des chemins différents.
Mh.
Et ce qui fait en sorte que vous avez des Engagés qui, c'est le cas dans leur manifeste d'ailleurs, promeuvent clairement les signes convictionnels dans l'administration,
c'est dû à une forme de conservatisme et de volonté de ne pas trop heurter des visions religieuses rigoristes de la société.
C'est pas le même chemin qu'Écolo, c'est-à-dire le chemin anti-discrimination, woke, instrumentalisé par l'islam politique.
Mais ils peuvent se rejoindre comme ils l'ont fait, en effet, à Anderlecht. L'un n'empêche pas l'autre.
OK.
Mais je prends dans mon bagage cette réflexion.
Oui, oui. Mais c'est-à-dire que donc vraiment, le vote des Engagés à Anderlecht est un vote conservateur.
Ah ben alors, c'est un vote conservateur.
Parce qu'un vote conservateur, c'est plutôt d'être fermement laïciste et fermement contre le-
Vous trouvez ? Ah moi, je trouve pas. Il y a pas plus progressiste que la laïcité. Il y a pas plus progressiste que-
Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'on conserve un status quo, on conserve un état de fait et vouloir le changer, je n'appellerai pas ça conservateur puisque par définition, c'est un changement.
Voilà des milliers d'années que les hommes voilent les femmes.
Mh.
Il y a rien de plus... c'est un objet quand même. Alors, des tas de femmes le portent pour des tas de raisons, notamment en pleine liberté et en plein droit.
Et jamais je ne m'amuserai à vouloir réglementer la manière dont les gens s'habillent en rue. Mais voilà des milliers d'années que les hommes voilent les femmes dans toutes les religions du monde.
Le judaïsme, le christianisme, où l'épître aux Corinthiens de Saint Paul est beaucoup plus cash et net que toutes les sourates du Coran sur le sujet.
Il faut voiler les femmes parce qu'elles sont un être, ce sont des êtres inférieurs et de tentation.
Et venir me dire : non, en fait, le progressisme, ce n'est pas la laïcité qui tend à protéger une partie du spectre, à savoir l'administration
des influences religieuses par le biais de la privation des signes convictionnels, mais c'est en fait le fait de ne pas les accepter.
Pardon, mais je trouve qu'il y a débat pour au moins un autre podcast. Ça me paraît pas aussi simple que ça.
Au moins un autre podcast, il nous reste quand même quelques instants. J'allais faire le lien avec donc votre livre Eros Capital.
Est-ce qu'il nous reste quelques-
Ah, il faut que je dise autre chose.
Voilà, voilà, mais est-ce qu'il nous reste quelques minutes pour en parler ?
Oui, il y a pas de souci.
Vous faisiez le lien donc avec les épîtres corinthiennes de Saint Paul. Votre vision que vous exprimez au travers de votre essai Eros Capital, quelle est-elle ?
Alors, en une minute, ça va être compliqué. Eros Capital est une... donc comme à chacun de mes essais philosophiques, j'essaye de répondre à une question dont je ne trouve pas la réponse ailleurs.
Et ça venait d'une réflexion toute simple. Et s'il était permis de considérer l'amour à la fois sur le volet des sentiments et à la fois sur le biais du charnel comme un immense marché ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe si on tente d'analyser ce qui nous arrive, notamment dans nos histoires d'amour, avec cette grille de lecture-là ?
Et si on tente d'analyser ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire de l'humanité depuis quelques centaines d'années sur cette grille de lecture-là ?
Évidemment, comme toutes les bonnes idées, j'en ai jamais été le premier à l'avoir et donc
je suis très vite tombé, notamment sur les féministes qui ont développé la théorie du continuum économico-sexuel, c'est-à-dire l'idée que de tout temps, il y a eu un échange entre les ressources des hommes et l'accès au sexe des femmes.
Ça a été développé vraiment par tout un monde féministe,
Paola Tabet, notamment. Et j'ai essayé de faire un essai qui, je crois d'ailleurs,
est en toute sincérité plutôt de bonne facture, mais qui est peut-être pas tombé dans l'époque la plus apte à le recevoir.
Parce que ça nous amène vite à des sujets-
C'est audacieux comme-
Pardon ?
C'est assez audacieux. Donc vous expliquez qu'aujourd'hui, on n'est pas prêt pour cet essai.
Alors, l'essai vaut ce qu'il vaut, mais je pense que l'époque, singulièrement l'année où il est sorti-
2020, c'est ça ?
Oui, on est en 2019, je sais plus. On est, on n'en est pas sorti d'un bouillonnement sur ces sujets qui n'a pas encore atterri.
Entre ce qu'est le consentement, ce qu'est la drague, ce qu'est la révolution des rapports entre hommes et femmes, ce qu'est l'identité sexuelle, ce qui est conservateur là pour le coup et ce qui ne l'est pas.
Là, je trouve qu'il y a pour le coup un vrai débat. Sur la psychologie évolutionniste. Donc l'idée que de la même manière que
la théorie de l'évolution, on parlait des créationnistes, la théorie de l'évolution a forgé nos yeux, nos oreilles, nos bras.
Elle a aussi forgé en partie notre manière de penser, en ce compris dans nos comportements vis-à-vis de l'autre sexe. Rien que de dire ça-
Mmm-hmm.
Je me fais déjà écharper par toute une partie du spectre féministe. C'est pas aussi simple que ça. Et vous pouvez pourtant le dire en ayant une absolue conviction d'égalité entre hommes et femmes.
C'est un sujet auquel je me suis confronté en entrant dedans et en m'immergeant dedans face à toute une série de contradictions que je n'ai pas tout à fait levées, mais qui a, je l'espère, produit un essai
intéressant, mais qui peut-être ne permettait pas à tout le monde de savoir où me classer et quoi en faire. Et voilà.
Complètement. Ce que vous exprimez dans Eros Capital, c'est l'idée qu'historiquement,
l'histoire et la nature de l'homo sapiens, comme vous aimez le dire dans l'essai, c'est qu'on est polygénique, c'est le terme que vous employez, et qu'il y a une petite minorité d'hommes qui avaient accès au sexe
et que c'était plutôt les mâles dominants.
Ah mais ça, ça fait relativement consensus dans la littérature scientifique.
Voilà, donc c'est la base à partir de laquelle-
Notamment pour ça, on n'a pas le temps d'aller dans les détails, que les hommes sont un peu plus grands que les femmes.
Il y a une forme de sélection qui s'est faite, qui s'est produite par ce biais-là.
Ok. Je ne suis pas un expert sur la question, mais admettons. Et que donc ça a créé une quantité de mâles frustrés qui ne pouvaient pas être en mesure de s'accoupler,
qu'il y a jamais eu de justice et de communisme vis-à-vis de l'accès au sexe,
et que ça implique donc une sélection comme voilà, vous venez de le dire apparemment, plus dominant, plus grand.
Et qu'aujourd'hui, il y a une libération, voilà, de la parole et du statut économique des femmes, que ça renverse le status quo, l'inégalité-
Ce qui n'est pas un problème du tout.
Voilà, ce n'est pas un problème, certainement pas. Et donc le renversement que vous pointez du doigt, c'est que les femmes se retrouvent aujourd'hui maîtres du jeu alors que c'était plutôt l'inverse avant.
Elles ont bien davantage, et c'est heureux, une faculté de... d'abord, elles sont complètement libres de leur choix, mais comme les hommes, elles se retrouvent face
à quelque chose que je ne peux exprimer que comme suit, à savoir il n'y a rien de plus discriminatoire que le marché amoureux.
C'est-à-dire que vous êtes autorisé, dès qu'il s'agit des choix amoureux, d'être exclusif, de préférer les grands, les petits, les catholiques, les musulmans, les laïques, peu importe, les blancs, les noirs.
Vous pouvez faire application des critères les plus exclusifs et discriminatoires qui ne sont absolument pas acceptés dans tout le reste de la vie, s'il s'agit d'accorder un emploi, un logement.
Mais en amour, on peut.
Mmm-hmm.
Et en amour, on peut faire des choix absolument scandaleux, aimer quelqu'un qui nous fait du mal, aimer quelqu'un qui n'a aucun mérite, aimer quelqu'un qui n'est… et c'est ça qui est extrêmement intéressant.
C'est-à-dire que l'amour est un marché, parce que c'est en grande partie de l'irrationnel, des choses qu'on ne choisit pas,
est un marché de l'arbitraire total, et est un marché quand même dans lequel les uns et les autres essaient de faire valoir leurs meilleurs atouts et leurs meilleures qualités.
Et effectivement, c'est un marché qui est complètement révolutionné depuis que les femmes ont une émancipation non seulement économique, mais juridique complète.
On a quand même vécu une époque, pas si lointaine, où une femme mariée avait encore besoin de l'accord de son époux pour ouvrir un compte en banque.
Enfin, c'est fou quand on y pense.
Ok, une révolution des termes…
Oui, mais aussi une révolution…
de cet accord.
Et une révolution de ce qui constitue des atouts de part et d'autre d'ailleurs. C'est pas être pour un homme aujourd'hui, c'est pas seulement être…
Excuse-moi, j'ai employé les termes de marché, d'accord, mais on va quand même remettre les termes, c'est oppression patriarcale millénaire et exploitation du corps des femmes.
Oui, bien sûr, ça ne fait…
Oui, ça me… parce que je voulais reprendre les termes que moi, j'ai employés.
Ça ne fait aucun doute, même si les femmes ont aussi participé au patriarcat. C'est pas aussi simple que ça.
Il y a des femmes qui entretiennent le patriarcat, qui y trouvent un intérêt, pas toutes. Et donc ce n'est pas aussi simple que ça.
Il n'y a pas un grand complot de la moitié de l'humanité contre une autre. Il y a un cheminement difficile et tortueux entre ce que la nature et la culture de l'être humain est.
Oui.
Et ce n'est pas forcément la même chose. Et je pense que la principale faculté de l'être humain, c'est de pouvoir intervenir sur sa propre nature par le biais de la culture.
Mais qu'il y a aussi des choses, notamment dans les comportements, dans nos priorités, qui passent par la nature et que c'est pas grave.
Nous sommes des êtres égaux, il y a aucun doute. Est-ce que nécessairement, on pense aux mêmes choses au même moment avec les mêmes priorités ?
Est-ce qu'on a la même stratégie de comportement, même innée, par rapport à l'autre sexe ? Je ne crois pas. C'est ça qui rend la modernité absolument fascinante.
Mmm. Et donc cette inégalité intrinsèque, enfin, ce que la nature nous renvoie et auquel on ne peut pas échapper, qu'est-ce que vous pointez là du doigt ?
Je sais pas. Je suis toujours en recherche sur le sujet. Je trouve ça extrêmement complexe parce que la différence entre le sexe et le genre, elle existe.
On voit bien, c'est évident, qu'il y a une série de personnes pour lesquelles on peut se dire : ben la nature s'est objectivement gourrée, quoi.
Il y a quelque chose qui est… des gens qui sont en transition pour de très très bonnes raisons. D'un autre côté,
les identités de genre et de sexe, je sens que c'est aussi en grande partie mouvant, qu'il y a un combat culturel là-derrière. Et…
À partir du moment où le genre est construit, effectivement, c'est sujet aux influences de la culture et de la société.
Ah oui, oui, nécessairement. Mais encore une fois, chez l'être humain, qu'est-ce qui est construit, qu'est-ce qui ne l'est pas ?
C'est, si vous voulez… Il n'y a aucune issue ni dans l'essentialisme à 100 % ni dans l'existentialisme à 100 %.
Il n'y a aucune issue dans le dire « je me construis complètement et je choisis de manière existentialiste sartrienne qui je suis, on n'est pas une femme, on le devient ».
Ce qui est plutôt…
Et ça, je crois qu'on est en train d'en revenir. Et l'essent…
Le constructivisme à 100 % est plutôt la position d'une certaine gauche.
Et l'essentialisme à 100 % ne marche pas non plus.
Plutôt la position de l'extrême droite.
Voilà, vous allez me dire, je suis un bon centriste. Moi, je pense que la nature et la culture s'entremêlent et qu'en fait, il faut beaucoup de prétentions pour arbitrer les choses.
Et en fait, plus on avance dans tous les sujets, même dans la théorie de l'évolution, on voit que c'est de plus en plus complexe de rester dans des catégories.
Alors c'est fascinant. Et voilà, mon petit essai, ce n'est qu'un petit jalon de ma réflexion sur le sujet et je la reprendrai quand j'aurai cinq minutes.
Et peut-être un peu trop essentialiste au goût de certaines féministes. C'est ça que vous me disiez ?
Je pense que c'est un essai qui est trop essentialiste au goût de certaines féministes, mais aussi trop essentialiste aux yeux de certains conservateurs.
Le jour de sa parution, ce bouquin a eu droit à une chronique d'Éric Zemmour.
Oui, j'allais le dire, oui. Éric Zemmour aime bien votre livre.
Ah non non non, il aimait mieux que ça. Heureusement, il n'a pas aimé tant que ça. Il trouvait que ça partait bien, mais que je reste trop pétri, je crois que c'est ça qu'il a écrit,
d'idées reçues, ça devrait vous plaire, d'idées reçues, préconçues, égalitaristes, entre les femmes.
Je suis content que monsieur Zemmour n'ait pas tout à fait apprécié mon livre.
D'accord, OK. OK, OK, très bien. Il va bientôt être l'heure de se quitter, malheureusement, François De Smet.
Voilà, quand je posais la question à Jean-Luc Ruck de… parce que voilà, c'est en fait finalement Les Engagés,
je parle d'eux parce que c'est aussi votre concurrent direct au sein de, voilà, d'un point de vue démographique, votre électorat est un petit peu le sien au niveau des ressources, au niveau des privilèges culturels et financiers.
Voilà, c'est un petit peu, voilà, vous vous battez sur le même terrain. Lui a terminé l'entretien en disant : « Mais on rediscutera de tout ça après les élections.
Un rapprochement est encore possible. » Est-ce qu'un rapprochement est encore possible avec Les Engagés ou bien est-ce que la porte est définitivement, définitivement fermée ?
Parce que c'est vous qui avez claqué la porte la dernière fois.
C'est une manière de voir les choses. C'est aussi eux qui ont dit non aux trois demandes que j'avais. Donc, je pourrais aussi dire que c'est eux qui ont claqué la porte.
Le récit politique, c'est toujours de dire que c'est l'autre qui est parti.
D'accord.
Mais les Engagés ne sont pas moins crédibles que moi sur le sujet. En politique, comme en amour, il faut éviter et les jamais et les toujours.
Si Les Engagés évoluent sur les trois sujets que nous ne pouvons pas doctrinalement laisser tomber.
L'exclusion de la N-VA, la laïcité…
C'est-à-dire arriver à comprendre que la N-VA n'est vraiment pas un parti comme les autres, même si c'est une auberge espagnole dans laquelle je reconnais qu'il y a aussi des conservateurs, des libéraux, des gens convenables et pas juste
des nationalistes purs sucre.
Mais bon voilà, ne plus avoir de naïveté à cet égard, avoir un vrai point de vue progressiste sur les sujets éthiques tels que le droit à l'IVG
et nous rejoindre sur notre vision de la laïcité politique plutôt que de parler d'impartialité de l'État tout en acceptant dans leur manifeste que les signes convictionnels ont leur place dans l'administration.
Si on arrivait à avancer sur ces trois sujets, pourquoi pas ? On pourrait discuter.
Si eux avancent et vous, vous ne vous voyez pas compromettre ces trois points-là.
Ben, c'est-à-dire que moi, je ne leur demande pas de remise en cause plus fondamentale que celle-là. Ces trois-là, c'est des points pour nous identitaires.
Parce que je pourrais parler avec eux de centrale nucléaire ou de fiscalité, mais on risquerait d'être d'accord. Donc,
c'est aussi parce que dans ces discussions, moi, c'est peut-être un tempérament, j'aborde directement les sujets qui fâchent et qui crissent pour voir si le chemin est possible.
Et je suis assez franc et exclusif là-dessus. Je ne vais pas essayer d'amener au piège en ayant d'abord des accords sur tout le reste.
Non. Si je vois que un, en l'occurrence, trois sujets vont poser problème, je vais essayer de savoir est-ce qu'on a un chemin possible ou pas. On n'avait pas.
François De Smet, merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous.
Pour ces minutes passées ensemble et je vous dis à très bientôt pour un prochain épisode. Au revoir. Vous l'avez compris, c'est chaud en ce moment chez DéFI.
Vous l'avez entendu, quand on a enregistré fin du mois dernier, François De Smet espérait que l'eau aurait coulé sous les ponts et que la situation aurait évolué.
Aujourd'hui, donc, le jour où je publie cet épisode, le 14 mars, ben, c'est vraiment pas le cas, on dirait. Je publie cette interview deux semaines après l'enregistrement et à ce stade, le conflit qui oppose le clan Maingain
au clan De Smet est toujours assez bouillant.
Olivier Maingain, ancien président de DéFI, qui reste évidemment une figure très importante du parti, a annoncé qu'il ne serait définitivement sur aucune liste lors des élections du 9 juin.
Voilà, on l'évoquait pendant l'interview, Olivier Maingain continue à exiger la démission du chef de cabinet de François De Smet en disant que c'était essentiel pour ramener de la crédibilité en interne ainsi que, je cite,
« quelques changements limités sur la liste régionale ».
Il a réaffirmé il y a quelques jours que jamais il ne portait d'accusations sans preuves. Donc dans un énorme pavé sur Facebook, concrètement, il pointe du doigt des inconsistances entre les différents récits et surtout, ben, le fait que
ouvrir une enveloppe scellée contenant les votes pour recompter les voix, ça doit se faire collectivement, en toute transparence.
Et ça peut pas, dit-il, être une initiative spontanée de Abdulla Mohamat, qui est donc le chef de cabinet en question, sur lequel il déverse par ailleurs toute une série d'attaques ad hominem.
Comme on l'a dit dans l'interview, c'est très clair qu'il n'a vraiment que très peu d'estime pour lui. Olivier Maingain, du coup, reste visiblement inébranlable sur cette question.
Pour lui, il y a bien eu tricherie et le compromis proposé a d'abord, dit-il, été accepté par François De Smet avant d'être finalement rejeté.
Et à l'heure où je vous parle, la tension est à son comble puisque un conseil général va se réunir vendredi 15, donc le lendemain de la publication de cet épisode, pour tenter de trancher la question.
Voilà, le timing, le timing, tout ça calculé. Pas du tout. Du coup, à l'heure où vous écoutez cet épisode, vous en savez sans doute plus que moi.
Peut-être que DéFI a explosé, peut-être que tout va bien, que la question est résolue. Je ne sais pas. Dans tous les cas, ils lancent officiellement leur campagne ce dimanche.
Sauf s'ils ont explosé. Mais normalement, ils lancent leur campagne ce dimanche. Voilà, mon analyse à ce stade, c'est que je ne sais évidemment pas si ces accusations sont justifiées.
Vous avez entendu les positions de chacun et en vrai, je vous avoue que ça m'intéresse assez peu. C'est très, voilà, c'est de la cuisine interne.
Mon point de vue, c'est surtout que tous ces conflits internes et l'amateurisme affiché vont, je pense, inévitablement impacter le score électoral du parti.
Qui n'est déjà pas un très grand parti puisqu'il a surtout du poids en région bruxelloise en fait. Sur ce, je vous dis à dans deux semaines pour un sujet sur les violences obstétricales. À très bientôt.